I had a dream last night that it was the best episode we've ever done. So I couldn't sleep the rest of the night, got in here, fired up the old machine, and I'm now waiting on these guys, and I am loose. I got a little bit of a sweat going, the hammies are pliable, flexible, and the jaw muscles are ready to really ask some tough questions and giggle at my funny little friend, Sean and Will. Guys, welcome to Smart Less. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
我昨晚做了一个梦，梦见这是我们做过最棒的一期节目。所以我整晚都睡不着，来到这里，启动了老机器，现在我正在等这几位，而且我很放松。我身上出了点小汗，大腿后侧的肌肉很放松、很柔软，面部肌肉也已经准备好提出一些尖锐的问题，并对我的搞笑小可爱朋友肖恩和威尔傻笑。伙计们，欢迎来到《SmartLess》。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. laughed so hard as I did today when we were standing on the street. We just come out of a meeting the three of us like adults like adults and Sean Sean starts to say something and he like he's doing right now he he undoes a top of a bottle of water and he's about to take his hip and or he's going to do it and Jason slaps it out of his hand. Lans on the ground. And Lans on the ground. Just a fun, just kind of fun little hair pull. Yeah, just a little fun fun fun.
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。我今天笑得最开心的一次，就是我们站在街上的时候。我们三个刚从一个会议出来，像成年人一样，像成年人一样，然后肖恩，肖恩开始说些什么，就像他现在这样，他拧开一瓶水的瓶子，正准备用他的屁股，或者他打算这么做，杰森一巴掌把它拍飞了。掉在地上。然后掉在地上。这只是一种有趣的，就像那种有趣的小恶作剧。对，就是一点点有趣。
A plastic bottle, nothing broke. So I reached down to grab it, because it falls at my feet, and I handed to Sean, and as he reaches for it, I just drop it right before he can grab it. Like it's Sean. That's twice.
一个塑料瓶，什么都没坏。所以我伸手去捡它，因为它落在我脚边，我把它递给肖恩，就在他伸手去拿的时候，我直接把它扔了，就在他抓到之前。就像是肖恩。那是第二次。
Twice, twice. And denied water. And as it lands on the ground, Sean reaches down to get it. And can grab it. Like it's not that twice. That's just one. That's just one. And as it lands on the ground, Sean reaches down to get it and Jason kicks it. And it goes flying. He hits a curb and goes under a park like construction truck. It explodes. It explodes. It's flying off the waters everywhere.
两次，两次。而且被拒绝了水。当它落在地上时，肖恩伸手去捡。然后抓住它。就像不是那样两次。那只有一次。那只有一次。当它落在地上时，肖恩伸手去捡，而杰森踢了它一脚。它飞了出去。它撞到一个路边石，滚到公园的施工卡车底下。它爆炸了。它爆炸了。水四处飞溅。
It's fucking funny. And I haven't laughed that hard. I failed the way it was. Because it was, it was high school all over again. It was like, it was a little bullying. Or just it, you know, it was high school all over again. It was like, it was a little bullying. You were just, you know, it was just fun. It was just, it's kind of, it was fun. Jay, did you like my cheesecake last night?
太他妈搞笑了。我好久没笑得这么开心了。我当时就破功了。因为那种感觉，就像是回到了高中时代。就像是，有点像校园霸凌。或者说，你知道的，就像回到了高中时代。就像是，有点像校园霸凌。你只是，你知道的，这就只是好玩。这其实，挺有意思的。杰，你喜欢我昨晚做的乳酪蛋糕吗？
Yeah, cheese. Now I would have liked it a little firmer, Sean. A little? Yeah, it was a little too fluff. You know, it wasn't as gooey as the last one, so I feel like we're making progress. I like that last one. No, I say this as a person, I can't even boil water.
对，奶酪。现在我希望它能再结实一点，肖恩。稍微点？对，它稍微有点太松软了。你知道，它没有上一个那么黏稠，所以我觉得我们在进步。我很喜欢上一个。不，我是以一个连水都烧不开的人的身份说这话的。
So the fact you cook anything is incredible. It's very impressive. But also, I didn't know, well, either that I've never made whipped cream in my life. I didn't know that you just pour half and half or whatever in a bowl. And whip it. And you just start this special.
所以你能做任何东西，这太不可思议了。这太令人印象深刻了。但同时，我也不知道，要么就是我这辈子从没做过鲜奶油。我不知道你只要把半对半奶油什么的倒进碗里。然后打发它。然后你就开始这个特殊的。
You just start whipping it. I was. My mind was there. I was like, Oh, you think it's a good idea that you've now learned how easy it is to make whip. I think so. I think so. I think you don't.
你只要开始打发它。我在。我的心思全在那。我就想，哦，你觉得现在学会做奶油有多容易是个好主意吗？我觉得是。我觉得是。我不这么认为。
I'm doing it tonight. Yeah, you missed out on a good cheesecake last night. Well, but then I found out then Sean told me that the secret ingredient that he does drive an hour and a half for. Yeah. I found out then Sean told me that the secret ingredient that he does drive an hour and a half for was a British chocolate Cadbury white chocolate bar. No, not Cadbury, it was another brand, but yeah. Another brand that we're not going to mention, I guess. We can't have you on, it's called Milky Bar.
我今晚就做。对，你昨晚错过了一个好吃的乳酪蛋糕。好吧，但后来我发现，肖恩告诉我，他愿意驱车一个半小时去买的那个秘密配料。对。我后来发现，肖恩告诉我，他愿意驱车一个半小时去买的那个秘密配料是一块英国吉百利白巧克力。不，不是吉百利，是另一个牌子，但对。另一个我们不打算提及的牌子，我猜。我们不能让你上节目，它叫Milky Bar。
Well, we already mentioned Cadbury, so we're kind of committed. But is that a thing? Is that normal that there's a white chocolate candy bar in most cheesecakes? Well, no, no. I just melted it to make kind of like the creamy part, it was one of many ingredients. But it's, you can all think. Sorry, you thought you tuned into Smart List. It's, it's cook-less this week. Baked-less. Yeah, yeah, I know. I was so obsessed with getting ingredients right. I drove an hour and a half to get it because they don't sell them in the United States.
好吧，我们已经提到吉百利了，所以我们算是一条船上了。但这算是一回事吗？大多数乳酪蛋糕里面放白巧克力糖块，这正常吗？好吧，不，不。我只是把它融化来做成那种奶香的部分，它是众多配料之一。但这，你们大家都可以想想。抱歉，你以为你收听的是《SmartLess》。这周是《烹饪少一点》（Cook-less）。《烘焙少一点》。对，对，我知道。我太执着于把配料弄对了。我开车一个半小时去买它，因为美国不卖这种。
And what did he do? Well, when he got there, he drove to another country. And he when he drove an hour and a half away to get this to what did he do while he was there? He's like, huh, well, look, here's a, here's a rare hamburger joint that we don't have near us. Yeah, that's why he went to portillos. To portillos.
他做了什么？好吧，他到了那里，他开去了另一个国家。当他开车一个半小时去买这个时，他在那里做了什么？他就像，哈，看，这里有一家我们附近没有的罕见汉堡店。对，这就是他去Portillos的原因。去Portillos。
Yeah, and he put a big burger in his face and a shake too, I bet. Yeah, I got a shake and a cake. And I got fries and a hot shake. And a shake for lunch. A cake fries and a hot dog. And then when you would be sandwiches, two beef sandwiches, one for body. And this is when you were on the mission to pick up a school bus? White chocolate. Yeah, well, I had picked up the white chocolate. Were you buying for all the kids in the school bus? No, I never get it.
对，我敢打赌他在脸上塞了一个大汉堡，还有一杯奶昔。对，我要了一杯奶昔和一个蛋糕。我还要了薯条和一个热奶昔。午餐要了奶昔、蛋糕、薯条和热狗。然后你会买三明治，两个牛肉三明治，一个给身体。这就是你当时在执行接校车任务的时候？白巧克力。对，好吧，我接了白巧克力。你是为校车上的所有孩子买的吗？不，我从来没买过。
So I bought like a little extra stuff and I put it in the fridge and I'll heat it up later. Good for you. Thank you. Guys, let's get started. Oh, wow, I thought we had, but. This is really exciting, guys, today. You're gonna freak out. Oh, it's your guest. Oh wow, I thought we had, but. This is really exciting guys today. You're gonna freak out.
所以我多买了一点，把它放在冰箱里，我待会儿加热。真为你高兴。谢谢。伙计们，我们开始吧。哦，哇，我还以为我们已经，但是。伙计们，今天这真的令人兴奋。你会大吃一惊的。哦，是你的嘉宾。哦，哇，我还以为我们已经，但是。伙计们，今天这真的令人兴奋。你会大吃一惊的。
Oh, it's your guest. It's my guest today. I'm so excited. We got my favorite red-headed firecracker here today. She's a self-proclaimed computer nerd and before becoming one of my all-time favorite full-fledged movie stars, she made people websites for free.
哦，是你的嘉宾。今天我的嘉宾。我太激动了。我们今天迎来了我最喜欢的红发小辣椒。她自称是个电脑极客，在成为我历来最喜欢的全职电影明星之一前，她曾免费帮别人做网站。
In fact, at 14 years old, she performed a PowerPoint presentation to title Project Hollywood. In order to convince her parents to let her drop out of high school. I moved to LA from Arizona to preserve her dreams of becoming an actress. Thankfully, that dream came true. So we could talk to her today. Her name is Emma Stone. Emma Stone. Emma Stone. Emma Stone. And Emma's a little under the weather. I'm a little under the weather.
事实上，在14岁时，她做了一个名为“好莱坞计划”的PPT演示文稿。为了说服父母让她从高中辍学。我从亚利桑那州搬到洛杉矶，为了实现她成为演员的梦想。谢天谢地，那个梦想成真了。所以我们今天能跟她聊聊。她的名字是艾玛·斯通。艾玛·斯通。艾玛·斯通。艾玛·斯通。艾玛身体有点不舒服。我身体有点不舒服。
Oh, that's so cool. I can't believe you showed up for us. Did you get into a big pile of bad co-class 9 Emma? I liked it. You know what? You've been there, right? Right, right. There's meetings for you. Yeah, listen, we're saving a seat for you.
哦，太酷了。真不敢相信你还为我们出场。艾玛，你是不是进了一堆糟糕的9班课？我很喜欢。你知道吗？你经历过，对吧？对，对。有专门针对你的会议。对，听着，我们给你留了个位子。
I know, thank you. I know. I knew it home or in a hotel. We're going to hotel. We're going to hotel. It's a home. I should have been alive for my first ever. Thanks for having me. What an open. Emma's been up. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
我知道，谢谢。我知道。我当时在家或者在酒店。我们要去酒店。我们要去酒店。这是家。我本来应该为我的第一次而活着。谢谢你们邀请我。多么开场。艾玛一直在。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。
对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起. 对不起。对不起。对不起。
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm and I was born blonde. But I was born hairless, but then I grew blonde hair. Okay. Hairless is my podcast. Sure. Give us the full.
对不起。我生来是金发。但我出生时没有头发，但后来我长出了金发。好吧。无毛是我的播客。当然。给我们讲讲全部。
Bravo. The, uh, yeah, I died. I read. Yeah, you were read for a while there, yes. For a long time. I was so much so that people thought it was, it was that you were Natch Red. Red Natch, but I, but I'm not red.
太棒了。那个，嗯，我染了。我红了。对，你有一段时间是红发，是的。持续了很长一段时间。我太红了，以至于人们以为那是，那是你是天然红。天然红，但我，但我不是红的。
Natch. But wasn't a true. My mother's red Natch. Yeah. People thought it was it was that you were Nat red red that I but I'm not red match. Well, it wasn't a true. My mother's red match. Yeah, yeah, you had to be careful with that. I have a son who's a match. Ginger. I love a match. Ginger. Oh my gosh, we ever love a match.
天然。但这不是真的。我妈妈是天然红。对。人们以为那是，那是你是天然红，但我，但我不是天然红。好吧，这不是真的。我妈妈是天然红。对，对，你得小心那个。我有个儿子是天然红。姜发。我喜欢天然红。姜发。哦，天哪，我们谁不爱天然红。
So filthy from the very beginning. Wait, am I I. Didn't you? That's not that ginge. That's what. Hey, man. Do you mean a second? Take a nap. I've been up for days. I'm so excited you're on the show with us, Emma. Thanks for having me.
从一开始就这么粗俗。等等，我是。难道你没有？那不是姜发。那是。嘿，伙计。你介意一秒钟吗？打个盹。我已经好几天没睡了。艾玛，你来我们的节目，我太激动了。谢谢你们邀请我。
But wait, didn't you diet originally like when you moved here and you felt like you weren't getting part, or something, I feel like I read something, and then you thought maybe your talent, which you're seeping talent, that that wasn't good enough. And that's what I was telling everyone. Yes, and that's what I kept saying. Right, like, no, no, no.
但是等等，你最初不是染发，比如当你搬到这里觉得接不到角色，或者别的什么，我觉得我读到过什么，然后你觉得也许你的才华——虽然你浑身散发着才华——那还不够好。这就是我一直在告诉大家的。是的，这就是我一直在说的。对，就像，不，不，不。
That hair had got to go. But you thought you had to dye your hair, is that true? Yeah, I was, because I moved to LA when I was 15. And so all of the things that I was auditioning for at that time were kind of, you know, like rolls for 15 year old girls at that time were a lot of girls that were very, I guess what I was up for was a lot of very blonde cheer
那个头发得换掉。但你以为你必须把头发染了，是真的吗？对，我是，因为我15岁时搬到了洛杉矶。所以我当时试镜的所有角色都有点像，你知道的，当时15岁女孩的角色很多都是很多女孩，我猜我当时竞争的是很多金发的啦啦队
literary kind of rolls and I didn't fit those very well. And so I thought if I dyed my hair brown, it would really set me up. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that'd go. You know what, great, Jason, when Rissie got her heart. I didn't get any parts after that either. But a couple of years later, I auditioned for Super Bad.
那种文学类的角色，我不太适合那些。所以我想如果我把头发染成棕色，这真的能帮到我。对，对，对，那会去。你知道吗，太棒了，杰森，当瑞丝得到她的角色时。之后我也没有接到任何角色。但几年后，我去试镜了《太坏了》。
And I was at the camera test for that. And Judd Apatow said, well, maybe she could have red hair because the other girl in the movie, who's my best red now, Martha McEyzek, had brown hair. And so we dyed my hair red. And the rest was, you know. What was, dude, is Sean's incredible research accurate? Were you really doing websites for people?
我在那部电影的镜头测试现场。贾德·阿帕图说，嗯，也许她可以有红头发，因为电影里的另一个女孩，也就是我现在的红发死党，玛莎·麦伊萨克，有着棕色头发。所以我们把我的头发染成了红发。接下来的事，你懂的。什么，老兄，肖恩令人难以置信的调查准确吗？你真的在帮别人做网站吗？
Like, are you a computer person? I was in that kind of 90s computer format. I don't know if you guys know, Angel Fire, Geocities, that kind of world where you did, a very primitive HTML. This is not coding by any means. I would not, if you, in fact, I don't have a computer now.
比如，你是个电脑达人吗？我在那种90年代的电脑格式里。我不知道你们知不知道，Angel Fire、Geocities，那种你可以做的世界，非常原始的HTML。这绝对不是编程。我不会，如果你，事实上，我现在没有电脑。
They lent me this computer to be able to do this with you guys. I'm like a neolud I know. But back then, I was very into the internet and learning about building drop-down menus and things like that. I mean, primitive, like 1998. Wow, I like that.
他们借给我这台电脑，好让我能和你们一起做这个。我简直是个新勒德分子。但那时候，我很迷恋互联网，了解如何构建下拉菜单之类的事情。我是说，非常原始，就像1998年。哇，我喜欢那样。
What are you looking for? When you're out there, you're looking. What are you looking for in a drop-down menu? Now, see, that's the thing. Key, that's the thing. When you want something to step, and this keeps me up at night. Like, if you want something, if somebody's looking to step into a really elite drop down menu. Yeah.
你在找什么？当你在那里的时候，你在找。你在下拉菜单里找什么？你看，这就是关键。关键，这就是关键。当你想要某样东西踏上台阶，这让我夜不能寐。比如，如果你想要什么，如果有人想涉足一个真正精选的下拉菜单。对。
If you're looking for a great drop down menu, you're in the market. Now, okay. It needs to be clear, clear funds. We're not using any comic sands on my drop down menu. Okay. We're hitting H any comic sands on my drop-down. That's all. Okay. We're hitting Hylvedic a heart. You now are completely, you don't have a computer at all.
如果你在寻找一个绝佳的下拉菜单，你正在市场上。现在，好吧。它需要清晰，清晰的字体。我的下拉菜单里绝不使用任何Comic Sans字体。好吧。我们绝不使用任何Comic Sans字体。就是这样。好吧。我们坚定地使用Helvetica。你现在完全没有电脑了。
I don't have a computer at all anymore. Come on. I really don't. What about an iPhone? I have an iPhone, but it's a very incredible new iPhone 15. I don't. She's all good. It looks like you want to get rid of your old one.
我完全没有电脑了。拜托。我真的没有。那iPhone呢？我有iPhone，但这是一个非常不可思议的全新iPhone 15。我没有。她一切都好。看起来你想扔掉旧的。
It is now. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that. We're done with that.
现在是了。我们受够那个了。我们受够那个了。我们受够那个了。我们受够那个了。我们受够那个了。我们受够那个了。我们受够那个了。
We're done with that. We enjoyed our experience, but whole mama was our heavy rotation. Sorry about that, America. Wait, so you do, but you do, do you do email off your phone then? I do email my phone and I, you know, just, just, I bet with my thumbs. So no social media, I know nothing else. No. No, not that. Come on.
我们受够那个了。我们享受过这段经历，但“Whole Mamma”曾是我们的常驻曲目。美国，对此我很抱歉。等等，所以你确实，但你确实，你用手机发邮件吗？我用手机发邮件，我，你知道，就，就，我用大拇指打字。所以没有社交媒体，我对其他一无所知。没有。没有那样的。拜托。
No. That's refreshing. Thanks so much. No, I was thinking the yesterday. I said to a friend of ours, I says to him, I says. He says friend? I says friend, I says. Yep. I said, you we should imagine, imagine the reset this planet
没有。这太令人耳目一新了。太感谢了。不，我昨天在想。我对我们的一个朋友说，我对他说，我。他说朋友？我对朋友说，我。对。我说，你我们应该想象一下，想象一下这个星球会得到怎样的重启
would get if we had no social media for six months globally. Yeah, people would be willing. The fucking reset would be incredible. What do you think would happen? Well, people would learn how to manage boredom, which I think is a lost talent. I know I've tried to teach my kids, like it's okay if you're bored.
如果我们全球有六个月没有社交媒体。对，人们会愿意的。他妈的重启将会是不可思议的。你觉得会发生什么？好吧，人们会学会如何应对无聊，我认为这是一个失落的天赋。我知道我一直在教导我的孩子们，比如无聊也没关系。
That's actually another word for relaxation. Like enjoy, take a breath. Being bored is okay. Not having anything to do at a red light or an elevator is a good time to kind of like reintroduce yourself to yourself for a minute. Well, yeah, do you ever do that thing? And then you're like,
那其实是放松的另一个词。比如享受，做个深呼吸。无聊是没问题的。在红灯前或电梯里无所事事，是花点时间重新向自己介绍自己的好时机。好吧，对，你有没有做过那种事？然后你会想，
well, you look at, I've been doing a lot lately, I don't know, where I look around and I go, everybody's on their phone, every moment. If there's a down moment. And sometimes it's reflexive because people are nervous or they feel insecure. Yeah. But when you wake up in the morning,
嗯，你看，我最近一直在做很多，我不知道，我环顾四周然后心想，每个人都在看手机，每一刻。如果有空闲时刻。有时候这是一种条件反射，因为人们感到紧张或者他们感到不安全。对。但当你早上醒来时，
you don't have like a loop that you like to do on a computer with every... Oh, this is good, yeah. Well, but, what's your computer loop? Well, you know, you hit the New York Times and your email and your calendar and you kind of get your shits together. I just do all that on my phone.
你没有那种你喜欢在电脑上用每个……哦，这个好，对。好吧，但，你的电脑循环是什么？好吧，你知道，你点开《纽约时报》、你的邮箱、你的日历，然后你差不多就把破事都理清了。我都在手机上做这些。
Okay. So I'm probably actually on my phone more than people that have a computer. But see, what I'm picturing here is that you've got no reason or excuse to get up out of the pillows. Correct. You're still in the feathers,
好吧。所以我可能实际上比有电脑的人花在手机上的时间更多。但你看，我在这里想象的是，你根本没有理由或借口从枕头堆里起来。没错。你还躺在羽绒堆里，
will you reach over, you grab your phone? Just in the foot, I'm just in a pile of feathers. Yeah, well, you sleep in a pile of feathers for real. What an angel. What an angel. I'm down with that. Well, what's like with a nice desktop, you could get out and into the living room
你会伸过去，抓起你的手机？就在这堆里，我只是一堆羽绒。好吧，你真的睡在一堆羽绒里吗？多像个天使。多像个天使。我挺喜欢的。好吧，如果有个漂亮的台式电脑，你就可以出来走到客厅
and join the world. Get yourself a desktop. Get it right. This is a great opportunity for a new segment I'm calling. JB, walk us through it. No, you don't want to follow my morning. All right, so Emma, which one of your rad projects are we going to talk about today? We're going to, there's so many, but I, okay, so you answer that first.
融入这个世界。去给自己买个台式机。弄对吧。这是一个开启我称之为“新板块”的好机会。JB，带我们了解一下。不，你不想遵循我的早晨安排。好吧，那么艾玛，我们今天要聊聊你的哪个超赞项目？我们要，有太多了，但我，好吧，那你先回答那个。
No, I don't know. Which one do you like to talk about? I want to talk about childhood. I want to talk about all these good stuff. I want to talk about it as your birthday last week. Happy birthday. That's thank you so much. Yes.
不，我不知道。你想聊哪一个？我想聊童年。我想聊所有这些美好的东西。我想聊聊上周是你的生日。生日快乐。非常感谢。是的。
Thank you. We love the GH. Can we guess the H? Oh, this might be mean, but sure, go ahead. No you. I mean, thank you. Are we allowed to guess the age? Can we guess the age? Oh, this might be mean, but sure, go ahead. No, no, no, no. How about, I'm going to go with 24? 25. Will?
谢谢。我们喜欢猜年龄。我们可以猜年龄吗？哦，这可能有点刻薄，但好吧，请便。不，你。我是说，谢谢。我们能猜年龄吗？我们可以猜年龄吗？哦，这可能有点刻薄，但好吧，请便。不，不，不，不。这样吧，我猜24岁？25岁。威尔？
I'm going to get real. Yeah, be real. I'm not going to play so much. Will and I work together when I was, I think, 19. Yes, that's true, really? That was a long time ago. That is true. That is true. So wait, then, then, then, then, long time ago. That is true. You're going to win then.
我要来真的了。对，说真的。我不打算瞎猜了。威尔和我合作时，我想我当时19岁。是的，真的吗？那是很久以前的事了。是真的。那确实是真的。所以等等，然后，然后，然后，很久以前的事了。是真的。那你赢定了。
So wait, then Sean, you go next. Okay. I was going to say late 20s. That's very cute, Sean, and sweet. True, I really don't know. Are you truly North of 30? I'm North of 30. Oh, well, she is 37.
所以等等，肖恩，你来。好吧。我本想说快30岁。肖恩，这真是太可爱太贴心了。真的，我真的不知道。你真的超过30岁了吗？我超过30岁了。哦，好吧，她37岁。
Oh, 35. You're the closest by far. Really? Yeah, 35. I'm young. You don't look 37. I was just guessing based on what the information. Oh really? Yeah, 35. The great name. I didn't you don't look 37. Now I was just guessing based on what the information is. Okay. Well sure.
哦，35岁。你是猜得最近的。真的吗？对，35岁。我很年轻。你看起来不像37岁。我只是根据信息盲猜的。哦，真的吗？对，35岁。好名字。我没觉得你看起来不像37岁。我只是根据已知信息瞎猜的。好吧。当然。
Well, okay. No, no, no, no, that's true. We did we did we did work. There was a long time ago. I know. What was the job? Do you remember? It was called the rocker. You didn't.
好吧，好吧，不，不，不，那是真的。我们确实，我们确实合作过。那是很久以前的事了。我知道。那是啥工作？你还记得吗？叫《摇滚之神》。你没有。
The rocker. Wait, the rocker. I still need to see and what was the other one I said I need to see the other day? Um, uh, hot rod. All right. Well, let's not go through my Emma go tell everybody who is wait the rocker. I still need to see and what was the other one I said I need to see the other day Rod All right, well, let's not go through my Emma go tell everybody who is in the rock nobody seen it who is in the rocker The cast is pretty hilarious. It was rain Wilson. Yeah Jason Sedacus. Yeah, you Bradley Cooper. Yeah, Fred Armason. Yeah
《摇滚之神》。等等，《摇滚之神》。我还是得去看看，我前几天说我得看的是哪一部来着？嗯，呃，《热血男儿》。好吧，那我们别翻我的了，艾玛快告诉大家，等等，《摇滚之神》。我还是得去看看，我前几天说我得看的是哪一部来着？《热血男儿》。好吧，那我们别翻我的了，艾玛快告诉大家，谁在《摇滚之神》里，没人看过这片，谁在《摇滚之神》里。演员阵容挺搞笑的。有雷恩·威尔逊。对。杰森·苏戴奇斯。对。你。布莱德利·库珀。对。弗莱德·阿米森。对。
I need who directed this? I'm a guy named Peter Catanio who directed the full Monty. Peter Catanio. Yeah, yeah. And John Glazer. John Glazer. Oh. The great John Glazer.
我需要知道谁导演的？一个叫彼得·卡坦奥的家伙，他导演了《光猪六壮士》。彼得·卡坦奥。对，对。还有约翰·格莱泽。约翰·格莱泽。哦。伟大的约翰·格莱泽。
Who did Hot Rod? Who directed Hot Rod? Was that, that wasn't your Moe, was it? No, it was. Yeah, gotcha. But, that cast was pretty, it was pretty wild. Yeah, we were in Toronto. We were in Toronto.
谁导演了《热血男儿》？那是，那不是你的莫（Mo），对吧？不，是。对，懂了。但是，那个演员阵容挺疯狂的。对，我们在多伦多。我们在多伦多。
And I feel like you weren't there for that long. I was there for a couple months. I was there for a week, maybe. And what kind of part were you playing, Emma? Well, I was playing the bass in a band that was fronted by, it was sort of a school of rock adjacent, would you say, well, by, it was sort of a school of rock adjacent, what do you say, Will? Yeah, yeah, I would.
我觉得你在那儿呆的时间不长。我在那儿呆了几个月。我呆了一个星期吧。艾玛，你当时演的是什么角色？嗯，我在一个乐队里弹贝斯，主唱是，这有点像是《摇滚校园》类型的，你会这么说吗，威尔？对，对，我会这么说。
Kind of story. Willy, what are you playing? Oh, I played the lead singer of a, of a hair band. Yeah. True story. I guess that's like, you gotta take that. And Bradley was the guitarist
某种故事。威利，你演什么？哦，我扮演一个长发金属乐队的主唱。对，千真万确。我想那就像，你得接受那个。布莱德利是吉他手
and from the, the bassist. No. But it was, but it was fun. But yeah, I mean, you have not, I'm trying to think, you just have not stopped working and doing awesome stuff since the moment I became aware of you. You've just been consistently just doing cool thing after cool thing, great film after great film.
和贝斯手。不。但它，但它很有趣。但是，是的，我的意思是，你没有，我在想，自从我注意到你以来，你真的就一刻也没有停止过工作和做超酷的事情。你一直在持续不断地做一件接一件酷炫的事情，一部接一部伟大的电影。
It's pretty remarkable. Not a lot of people. I'm rare. Basically, you haven't done anything as shitty as the Rocker since The Rocker is what Will is saying. I've done way worse movies than The Rocker since The Rocker. Oh my God. Subjective. Well, I think.
这相当了不起。没几个人能这样。我是个珍品。基本上，威尔的意思是，自从《摇滚之神》之后，你再也没拍过像《摇滚之神》那么烂的电影了。自从《摇滚之神》之后，我拍过比它烂得多的电影。天哪。主观臆断。好吧，我觉得。
Yeah, it's great. It is good. Let's not go too deep through the IMDB era. I want to know. I met you once very briefly. You were so kind years and years ago, blah, blah, you never remember. I think it was at SNL. But I was like, oh my God, that's Emma Stone. And then so when I did my research for today, I didn't know that your name was Emily.
对，这很棒。这确实不错。我们别在IMDB时代挖得太深了。我想知道。我曾经非常短暂地见过你一次。你多年前非常善良，巴拉巴拉，你肯定不记得了。我想那是在《周六夜现场》。当时我就想，哦，天哪，那是艾玛·斯通。然后当我为今天做功课时，我才知道你的名字叫艾莉森。
I wanna know these guys. I know why it's called Emma, but I want you to tell these guys why it's called, why you changed it to Emma. And then I also wanna know about your dog bakery thing that you worked at because I have a friend who lives in Arizona, who has a company, it's a dog poop company. She picks up poop dog poop for you just call her and pick up diamond. But it was in Scottsdale. Oh, that's where I'm from. I know. That's amazing.
我想了解这些家伙。我知道为什么叫艾玛，但我想让你告诉大家为什么叫艾玛，你为什么要改成艾玛。然后我还想知道你之前工作过的那个狗狗面包店的事情，因为我有个朋友住在亚利桑那州，她有一家公司，是一家狗屎公司。她专门帮你收狗屎，你只要打电话给她，她就会来收钻石。但那是在斯科茨代尔。哦，那是我的老家。我知道。太惊人了。
Well, my name was. Have you noticed like there's been less dog poop around when you go home? You know, now that you're getting shot, Sean's friends. I mean, it used to be absolutely everywhere. Hi, I'm, but her gig, her gig is just, she's just a freelance. She just goes around town and she's looking for just spare poop that's unclaimed. Sure, yeah, that's just, you call it up. If you don't want to pick up your dog poop and she, it's called poop troll. Sherry's poop. Who's compensating her?
好吧，我的名字是。你有没有注意到，当你回家时，周围的狗屎变少了？你知道的，既然你有肖恩的朋友罩着。我的意思是，过去到处都是。嗨，我是，但她的工作，她的工作只是个自由职业者。她只是在镇上四处转悠，寻找无主的备用狗屎。当然，是的，你只要打电话就行。如果你不想捡你狗屎，她，这叫“狗屎巡逻队”。雪莉的狗屎。谁在付她薪水？
The city? Her clients. People who don't want poop in their lawn, man. Yeah. I'm with you. Wait. So you just let your dogs kind of run free on your own lawn, like all week, and then poop control comes and picks everything up.
市政府？她的客户。那些草坪上不希望有狗屎的人，老兄。对。我赞同。等等。所以你就是让你的狗狗在自己的草坪上自由奔跑，持续一整周，然后狗屎控制中心就会来把所有东西都收走。
That's right. The gardener comes over, picks up the poop. Yeah. Like she's not blowing the leaves and stuff. There's a few bits of hope. Wow. Wow. I don't know 30 jokes in there.
没错。园丁过来，把狗屎收走。对。就像她不吹落叶之类的。有一些零星的希望。哇。哇。我不知道里面有30个笑话。
I didn't know where to. Well, it's kind of I brought it up. It's such a funny job. You take a tight five and gather them and then go back to us. But wait, a dog bakery, you worked at a dog bakery when you were a teenager. Yeah, okay. I worked at dog bakery when I moved to LA when I was 15, called Three Dog Bakerie at the Farmers Market.
我都不知道该……好吧，这有点像是我提出来的。这真是个有趣的工作。你先组织好一个简短的五分钟段子，然后再回到我们这儿来。但等等，狗狗面包店，你十几岁时在一家狗狗面包店工作过。对，好吧。我15岁搬到洛杉矶时在一家狗狗面包店工作过，叫农夫市场的“三只狗面包店”。
At the Grove? At the Grove. I used to go there. You worked there? Yes, for, well, I mean, not for long, for like maybe six months. Wow. So, wait, Johnny, this was pre-Ricky? Yeah, this was years ago, years and years ago, right?
在格罗夫购物中心？在格罗夫。我以前经常去那儿。你在那儿工作过？是的，嗯，我是说，没干多久，大概六个月吧。哇。所以，等等，强尼，这是在瑞奇之前吗？对，这是多年前，好多年以前了，对吧？
This was when I was 20, it's 20 years ago. Yeah, that's when I had my two other dogs. I used to go there to shop for them. Do you think that we ever ran into each other then? Probably. Probably. I think the, I think word would have got it out that Will and Grace's Sean Hayes was there.
那是我20岁的时候，那是20年前。对，那是我养另外两只狗的时候。我以前经常去那儿为它们买东西。你觉得我们那时候偶遇过吗？可能吧。可能吧。我觉得，我觉得消息肯定会传开，说《威尔与格蕾丝》的肖恩·海斯在那儿。
I think you're right. I think I would have told everybody. Guaranteed. You probably had to show my team. Oh my God. Okay, so we, I must not have been working those hours. We'll be right back. SmartLess is sponsored by BetterHelp.
我觉得你说得对。我想我会告诉每个人的。绝对的。你可能得向我的团队展示。天哪。好吧，所以我们，我当时一定没上那个班。我们马上回来。《SmartLess》由BetterHelp赞助。
So in my family, which includes my friends, my friends are my family, we give gifts for the holiday season, but it's becoming less about the gifts and more about the time spent with each other, which is really, really important, especially as you get older. So whether or not your family gives gifts during the holidays, you get to define how you give to yourself, right? And the holidays are a great time to do that. So whether it's by starting therapy,
所以在我的家庭里，其中包含我的朋友们，朋友就是我的家人，我们在假期里会互赠礼物，但比起礼物，它越来越倾向于彼此陪伴的时间，这真的非常非常重要，随着年龄增长尤其如此。所以，无论你的家庭在节日期间是否送礼物，你都可以自己定义你如何对自己付出，对吧？而假期是这样做的绝佳时机。所以，无论是通过开始心理治疗，
going easier on yourself during the tough moments, or treating yourself to a day of complete rest, remember to give yourself some love this holiday season. I always feel better going into therapy, and if it's taught me anything it is to give back to myself, I always schedule time for myself, and I allow myself to not feel guilty if I sleep in one day or take a few moments for myself,
在艰难时刻对自己宽容一点，还是用一整天的彻底休息来犒劳自己，在这个节日里别忘了给自己一些爱。我总是觉得去做心理治疗能让我感觉更好，如果它教会了我什么，那就是回馈自我，我总是为自己安排时间，如果有一天我多睡了一会儿或者花了一点时间独处，我也允许自己不感到内疚，
so I hope you feel the same. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help, a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. In the season of giving, give yourself what you need with BetterHelp.
所以我希望你也有同感。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线进行，旨在提供便利、灵活并适合你的日程。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与持证心理治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。在这个奉献的季节，用BetterHelp给予自己所需。
Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartLess today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHLP.com slash SmartLess. We get support from Viori clothing. This holiday season spreads some joy with the gift of Viori. Picture this. Super comfy joggers, leggings that move with you, and cozy hoodies that make every day feel like a weekend. Or just picture me, because I'm wearing all of that right now. Viori's got the perfect blend of style and comfort for your loved ones, whether the
今天就访问 BetterHelp.com 满减斜杠 SmartLess（BetterHelp.com/SmartLess）即可在第一个月享受 10% 的折扣。网址是 BetterHelpHLP.com 满减斜杠 SmartLess。我们得到了 Viori 服装的支持。这个节日季，用 Viori 的礼物散播一些欢乐。想象一下。超级舒适的慢跑裤，随你而动的打底裤，以及让每一天都感觉像周末的舒适连帽衫。或者干脆想象我，因为我身上正穿着所有这些。Viori 为你的挚爱完美融合了时尚与舒适，无论是健身爱好者还是随时随地追求时尚的人。
gym buffs are just looking good on the go. Wrap up warm with smiles and a touch of flair with Biori's active wear and athlete's shirt. It's like giving a big cozy hug wrapped in a gift box. And let's be real, who would love that? Guys, you know the great thing about doing a podcast, I can wear anything I want. Guess what I wear, Biori? Because directly after doing these ads, I'm going to go to the gym.
用 Viori 的运动服和运动衫带来温暖的微笑和一丝时尚感。就像送上一个包裹在礼盒里的大大、温暖的拥抱。说实话，谁会不喜欢呢？伙计们，你知道做播客最棒的一点是什么吗？我可以穿任何我想穿的。你猜我穿什么？Viori！因为做完这些广告后，我就要去健身房了。
And I'm going to be wearing the same thing I'm in as I'm talking to you at the gym. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Thank you to State Farm for supporting this episode. Think of all the amazing things in life that are expressions of just you. For instance, the song you stream over and over again,
我将穿着跟现在跟你说话时一模一样的衣服去健身房。Viori 是对你幸福的投资。对于我们的听众，他们提供首次购买享 8 折优惠。快去 Viori.com/smartless 购买地球上最舒适、最百搭的服装吧。网址是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 满减斜杠 smartless（VUORI.com/smartless）。你不仅可以获得首次购买 8 折优惠，还可以享受美国境内满 75 美元免运费以及免费退货服务。访问 Viori.com/smartless，探索 Viori 服装的多功能性。感谢 State Farm 对本期节目的支持。想想生活中所有那些只属于你自己的精彩表达。比如，你一遍又-遍循环播放的歌曲，
while you're in your 13th hour of gaming at four in the morning with all the lights up, trying not to wake up your roommates, or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcasts that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back, or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bowl cut
当时你正处于凌晨四点的第13小时游戏时间，屋里的灯全开着，尽量不吵醒你的室友，或者是你在去健身房的路上以及回程中最适合听的前六大喜剧播客上与朋友分享的推荐，甚至是你新的发型，那可能（也可能不是）是一个来自90年代的史诗级锅盖头，但愿它是。所有造就了“独一无二的你”的事物，都带来了全方位的不同。State Farm 相信保险也应该以同样的方式运作。你的计划，你的保障选择可以由你个性化定制，并且能够通过选择适合你的选项来挑选你想要的计划，比如选择将你的房屋和汽车保单捆绑在一起，这就是 State Farm 个人价格计划的全部意义所在。以专属于你的实惠价格获得你想要的保障。
from the 90s and hopefully is. Everything that makes you, you, makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way. Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you, and the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you, like choosing to bundle your home and auto policies, is what the State Farm Personal Price Plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you.
那么，你准备好让事情变得个性化了吗？今天就致电或访问 StateFarm.com，创建你的 State Farm 个人价格计划。价格因州而异，客户选择的选项、可用性和资格可能会有所不同。好了，回到节目中。告诉大家你为什么把名字从“Emily”改成了“艾玛”。好吧，这是因为，最初我的名字被占用了
So, are you ready to make things personal? Call or go to StateParm.com today to create your State Farm Personal Price Plan. Price is very by state, option selected by customer availability and eligibility may vary. All right, back to the show. Tell these guys why you changed your name from Emily Tama. Well, it was, originally my name was taken
在演员工会。对。当我16岁拿到卡的时候。所以已经有一个Emily·斯通了。哇。所以最初我把它改成了Riley，因为当你告诉一个16岁的孩子他们可以随便改名字。对。你就会选一个很酷的名字。所以最初我把它改成了Riley，因为当你告诉一个16岁的孩子他们可以随便改名字。对。你就会选一个很酷的名字。所以我当时想，我要叫Riley。
at screen actor's guild. Right. When I got my card when I was 16. So it was an Emily Stone. Wow. And so I originally changed it to Riley because when you tell a 16 year old that they can just change their name. Right. You pick a cool name. And so I originally changed it to Riley because what do you tell a 16 year old that they can just change their name. Right. You pick a cool name. And so I was like, I'll be Riley.
对，第一点。你本可以把它改成艾玛，中间名是莉。艾玛·莉·斯通。对吧？你知道的。我不知道我能不能驾驭三个名字。好吧。他妈的，有没有可能你20年前给她打电话？你能20年前给我打个电话吗？对，对，对，非常快。等一下。我们暂停一下。对，对，对。
Right number one. You could have changed it to Emma middle name Lee. Emma Lee stone. Right? That you know. I don't know if I could pull off being a three-nameer. Okay. Fuck is there any way you could call her 20 years ago? Could you call me 20 years ago really quick? Yeah, yeah, yeah, real quick. Hold on a second. We'll pause. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
然后我们只是……但这确实是真事，对吧？那确实是真事。所有因为……SAG（演员工会）而改名的人，因为已经有人叫……对。迈克尔·J·福克斯，我想是因为已经有一个迈克尔·福克斯了，对吧？其中一个很棒的例子是，迈克尔·凯顿不就是迈克尔·道格拉斯吗？
And then we'll just... Then he's a real thing though, right? That is a real thing though. All people who changed their names because of... Sack, because there's already somebody... Yeah. Michael J. Fox, I think, was because there was already a Michael Fox, right? One of the great ones is isn't, I feel like Michael Keaton is Michael Douglas.
哦，哇。哦，真的吗？他把姓氏改成了凯顿，因为迈克尔·道格拉斯已经是迈克尔了。等等，我刚知道，我刚知道阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯的真名是阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦。这不是真的。不是。这太奇怪了。太奇怪了。
Oh, wow. Oh, really? And he changed his last name to Keaton because Michael Douglas was Michael. Wait, I just learned, I just learned Albert Brooks's real name is Albert Einstein. That's not true. No. It's weird to go. That's weird to go.
这太不可思议了。他哥哥是鲍勃·爱因斯坦，你知道的，“超级大卫·奥斯本”。那是鲍勃·爱因斯坦，那是阿尔伯特的哥哥。不过不管怎样，从Emily到Emma。从Emily到Emma是因为，好吧，因为你在模仿辣妹组合，对吧？对。是的，她以阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦命名是因为那个名字是免费的。没错。
That's unbelievable. His brother is Bob Einstein, you know, Super Dave Osborne. That was Bob Einstein and that's Albert's brother. But anyway, Emily to Emma. Emily to Emma because, well, because you're trying to get to the spice girls, right? Yes. Yeah, she named Albert Einstein because that was free. That's true.
那个现在免费了。没人用了。等等，所以你改成了Emma。我改成Emma是因为在成长过程中，我是一个正常人——我的意思是，直到今天我依然是——但一个巨大的，一个巨大的，抱歉，我在大舌头。因为所有美好的事物，我已经四天没睡了。你需要打个盹。
That one's free now. Not being used anymore. Wait, so you went to Emma. I went to Emma because growing up, I was a norm, I mean, still to this day, I am, but an enormous, an enormous, sorry, I'm slurring. From all of the good, I've been up the four days. You need to take a nap.
对，我得打个盹。我曾经是辣妹组合的超级粉丝。里面有个Emma，也就是“宝贝辣妹”。不会吧。为她疯狂。对，我超爱那个。我们有机会，当我在，你知道的，上小学二年级或三年级时，我要求老师叫我Emma，但他们没叫。从来没坚持下来。但后来我有机会
Yeah, I gotta take a nap. I was a huge spice girls fan. And there was Emma who was baby spice. No way. Crazy about her. Yeah, I love that. We had the opportunity, when I was in, you know, like second or third grade, I asked the teacher to call me Emma, but they didn't. It didn't ever stick. But then I had the chance to do
永久地改了。然后我就成了Emma。我太喜欢了。你后来见过辣妹组合吗？见过。哦，她知道这个。我现在见过辣妹组合了。我想，我想她知道，因为她准备了一件她签过名的非常特别T恤。上面写着，从一个Emma到另一个Emma之类的话。挺酷的。你当时克制住了吗？还是你根本没克制住？我完全没克制住。
it permanently. And here I am. I love that. Have you met the spice girls since? I have. Oh, she know that. I've met the spice girls now. I think I think she does because she didn't really special tshirt that she had signed. It was like, from one Emma too, another kind of thing. It was pretty cool. Did you keep it together? Or did you just keep it together at all? I did not keep it together at all.
但我得说，就在我见到她们的前一晚，我们正要去英国看她们的演唱会，那是她们在2019年举办的几年前的重聚巡演。在前一天晚上，我去参加了一个朋友家里的派对，魔术师大卫·布莱恩也在那儿。他表演了一个，简直是惊人的魔术。他表演了这个纸牌魔术，然后是整个过程，这是一个幻觉，一个幻觉。
But I will say, the night before, I met them, we were going to their concert in England when they did a reunion tour a couple of years ago in 2019. And the night before, I went to a party at somebody's house and the magician David Blaine was there. And he did a, just an astounding trick. He did this card trick and then it was this whole thing and it was an illusion, an illusion.
他掏出手机，那张牌倒映在某个人脚上的照片里，你知道的，在船上某个人的眼镜里。那是个疯狂的东西，我激动坏了。现在这也是一个故事，正如我马上要告诉你昨天发生的一个故事一样。我激动得跑了起来。我想，我简直受不了了
And he pulled up his phone and the card was reflected in a picture on someone's foot, you know, in the glasses of someone on a boat. And it was this crazy thing and I got so excited. Now this is a tale as well this time because I'm about to tell you a story from yesterday as well. I got so excited that I ran. I was like, I can't stand it
因为我是魔术的超级粉丝，我简直激动得受不了了，因为我是魔术的超级粉丝。我受不了了，然后我跑了起来。我当时穿着这些，这些高跟靴。我在木地板上滑倒了——这是在辣妹组合演唱会的前一晚。滑倒了，我的手臂向后甩到身后。然后我他妈把肩膀摔断了。这是什么时候？2019年，2019年的夏天。
because I'm such a big fan of magic and I couldn't stand it because I'm such a big fan of magic. And I couldn't stand it and I ran. And I was wearing these, these heel boots. And I slipped on the wood floor this is the night before the Spice Girls concert. Slipped, my arm went back out behind me. And I broke my fucking shoulder. When was this? 2019, the summer of 2019.
所以第二天我本该去观看辣妹组合的演唱会的。当时我想，我绝不可能错过这个。所以我们在英国买了一个这种东西，从Boots药妆店买的，这个小吊带。我甚至还没拍X光片。我去了，我当时痛得要命，以至于在那种情况下见到辣妹组合
So the next day I was supposed to go to the Spice Girls concert. And I was like, there is no way on Earth I'm missing this. So we got in England, one of these things from boots, the drugstore, this little sling. And I hadn't even gotten an X-ray yet. And I went and I was in so much pain that actually meeting the Spice Girls under those circumstances
可能反倒更好，因为这样我就没法在她们面前那样了。你很兴奋。你很兴奋。你很兴奋。而且你的兴奋被疼痛大大克制了。痛得太厉害了，以至于我说，很高兴见到你们。哦，天哪。
was probably better so I couldn't do that in front of them instead. And you're excited. And you're excited. And you're excited. And you're so tempered by the pain. It was so tempered by the pain that I was like, it's amazing to meet you guys. Oh my god.
感觉太残酷了。断成了两截。然后就在昨天，我有骨密度问题。这很明显，因为我昨天把脚趾摔断了。没有。我真的断了。我昨天把脚趾摔断了。没有。我真的断了。你在开玩笑吗？做什么？
Like it was so brutal. It was broken in two places. And then yesterday, I have bone density issues. That's clear because I broke my toe yesterday. No. I did. I broke my toe yesterday. No. I did. Are you kidding me? Doing what?
从淋浴间出来。对。好吧，你本来就不应该躺在淋浴间里。什么叫从里面出来？我知道。你是不是不小心踩到什么上了？我把它重重地撞在某个东西上，现在它完全又黑又青，一团糟。
Getting out of the shower. Yeah. Well, you shouldn't be lying down in the shower. What do you mean, getting out of it? I know. Are you accidentally stopped in on time? I slammed it into something and now it's completely black and blue and all messed up.
刚洗完澡。是啊。嗯，你不应该躺在淋浴间里。你是什么意思，刚出来？我知道。你是不小心按时停下来了吗？我把它猛撞到什么东西上了，现在完全青一块紫一块的，乱七八糟的。
It's like I sing it all day. Anyway. And you can show it up for us today. God bless you. Yeah, I heard you know the castle. It's a dream sing it all day. Anyway. And you're sick and you showed up for us today. God bless you. Yeah, I heard you're not canceled. It's a dream. This is incredible.
就像我整天都在哼唱一样。不管怎样。你今天能来捧场真是太好了。上帝保佑你。是啊，我听说你知道那个城堡。那真是一个梦想，整天都在哼唱。不管怎样。你生病了还能来捧场真是太好了。上帝保佑你。是啊，我听说你没有被封杀。这真像个梦。这太不可思议了。
Are you kidding? I'm sitting on a computer with headphones. This is a love book. Half of one of those excuses would have made me cancel this thing. God, I was just thinking. I would give. I was so excited for this. I would give anything for improved bone density.
你在开玩笑吗？我正坐在电脑前戴着耳机。这是一本爱情书。这些借口哪怕有一半也能让我取消这事了。天哪，我刚才还在想。我愿意付出。我太为此兴奋了。为了提高骨密度，我愿意付出一切。
Yeah. Sorry, just sidebar. Sidebar. We need to take, what is it, boniva or something? Yeah, boniva. There's some pill to help our bone density. But I've got seven bones. Before I was 30, I broke seven bones. Am I? Isn't that crazy? So then you seriously looked into this. You seriously do have a lot of issues. Yeah, I have. There's an endocrinologist was like, we got to talk about, like something's up with you. Right.
是的。抱歉，插个话。插个话。我们需要吃，那个叫什么来着，邦维iva还是什么的？对，邦维iva。有一些药丸可以帮助我们的骨密度。但我有七根骨头。在我30岁之前，我骨折过七根骨头。我是吗？这不是很疯狂吗？所以你真的去查了这个。你真的有很多问题。对，我有。有个内分泌学家说，我们得谈谈，你身上好像有点毛病。对。
And did he come up with anything? Just that I need to take a lot of vitamin D and calcium and do apparently weight bearing exercises, like heavy lifting is what creates more bone density. Well, you could just drink milk and eat, like dumplings from Chinchin, like Sean. Jesus. He has a glass of milk four times a day. No, I have a glass of milk with dinner every night.
他查出什么结果了吗？只是说我需要摄入大量的维生素D和钙，显然还要做负重运动，比如举重才能增加骨密度。好吧，你也可以像肖恩那样喝牛奶，吃钦钦饺子。天哪。他一天喝四次牛奶。不，我每天晚饭时喝一杯牛奶。
No, you don't. I really do. You should see. Why not? It's good for you. That's crazy. It's good for you. It's fine.
不，你没有。我真的喝。你应该看看。为什么不喝？这东西对你有好处。这太疯狂了。这对你有好处。没事的。
We used to sit at dinner drinking a glass of milk. Yeah, that's not a week ago. I just, I just stop. Are you just doing it to be adorable? Are you really enjoy it? No, he's just what he does. No, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I thought I saw the week ago. So I just, I just stop. Are you just doing it to be adorable? Or you really enjoy it? No, he's, this is what he does. No, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,. So listen, I wanted to see some other reasons around medical stuff. I wish this was just a gallon of milk.
我们过去常常坐在晚饭桌旁喝一杯牛奶。对，那不是一周前的事吗。我只是，我只是不喝了。你这么做只是为了显得可爱吗？还是你真的很喜欢？不，他就是这样的人。不，我，我，我，我，我想我看到是一周前的事。所以我只是，我只是不喝了。你这么做只是为了显得可爱吗？还是你真的很喜欢？不，他，这就是他做的事。不，我，我，我……所以听着，我想看看关于医疗方面的其他原因。我希望这只是一加仑牛奶。
I know, I know, I know. You're so fast. But is it true because you have one of those cool like million billion dollar voices too? Is it true that you first of all didn't know you had asthma until you had an asthma attack while filming EZA, which I read?
我知道，我知道，我知道。你反应太快了。但这是真的吗，因为你也有那种酷炫的价值几百万十亿美元的嗓音？这是真的吗，首先你根本不知道自己有哮喘，直到你在拍《超凡蜘蛛侠》时哮喘发作，我是这么看的？
And the other thing is, did you really have a condition when you were a baby because you cried too much? Call it, made your voice. Is that true? Yeah. Because you were colloquy that gave you a rest, people. Like extremely colloquy for five months.
还有一件事，你当婴儿的时候是不是真的得过什么毛病，因为你哭得太多了？可以说是，影响了你的嗓音。这是真的吗？对。因为你得了肠绞痛，各位。极其严重的肠绞痛，持续了五个月。
What's colloquy? Can you imagine now having a kid, I cannot imagine having a colloquy baby to that extent. Five, five. What does that mean, colicky? Colicky is apparently a condition where your stomach is killing you. Like there's, you're in a lot of pain. I am.
什么是肠绞痛？你可以想象现在养个孩子，我无法想象养一个那么严重的肠绞痛婴儿。五个月，五个月。这是什么意思，肠绞痛？肠绞痛显然是一种让你的胃痛得要命的病症。就像有，你感到非常痛苦。我是。
Everything I can talk about is just my medical. No, I know. It's fascinating. But here's what I think it is. It is the intestines or part of the GI tract that is still developing and unkinking itself and there is a kick in the nose. It still needs to grow to release itself and it takes a couple of weeks and the babies are miserable.
我能谈论的只有我的病情。不，我知道。这很着迷。但我觉得这是怎么回事呢？是肠道或胃肠道的某个部分仍在发育和自我舒展，里面好像有个结。它还需要生长来释放自己，这需要几个星期，而婴儿们痛苦不堪。
Yeah. So it was like if I was awake, I was screaming myself horse every day and I think it was very, very traumatizing for my parents. I see. You know what's good for bone densities, though, some of those the astronauts, you know that thing, the power plate thing, the vibrates, that's supposed to be good for bone density. Oh, thanks. Isn't that kind of a fifties thing to a little belt around you that she's wearing? I read it once over a glass of milk. I was straight. I want to know, let's get to the career stuff because it's really interesting. Okay, great. How would you hang on?
对。所以就好像只要我醒着，我每天都会大喊大叫把自己嗓子喊哑，我觉得这对我父母来说是非常非常痛苦的经历。我明白。不过你知道对骨密度有什么好处吗，宇航员用的那种东西，你知道那个电动踏板吗，会振动的那种，据说对骨密度有好处。哦，谢谢。这不有点像五十年代的玩意儿吗，腰上围着一个小带子？我曾经在一杯牛奶上读到过这个。我很正经。我想知道，我们来聊聊职业生涯吧，因为这真的很有趣。好的，太棒了。你打算怎么，稍等。
How would you, baby? Let's just do a quick, how would you, baby? Two and a half. Ah, sweet boy girl. Girl. Girl, sweet. I didn't know that. That's so fantastic.
你打算怎么，宝贝？我们简单做个调查，你打算怎么，宝贝？两岁半。啊，甜蜜的男孩女孩？女孩。女孩，真甜。我不知道。太棒了。
Congratulations. Thank you so much. Thank you. With your husband who you met at SNL, did you meet him at SNL? True. Dave McCarrie. Yeah.
恭喜。非常感谢。谢谢。你的丈夫，你们是在《周六夜现场》认识的吗？你们是在《周六夜现场》认识的吗？真的。戴夫·麦卡里。对。
And is he, what does he do with SNL? He you meet him at SNL? Did you meet him at SNL? Did you meet Dave McCarrie? Yeah. And is he, what does he do with SNL? He was a writer-director there for about five years. Oh, nice. Doing digital shorts. And you met him there? I met him there, yeah.
那他是，他在《周六夜现场》做什么？你们是在《周六夜现场》认识的吗？你们是在《周六夜现场》认识的吗？你认识戴夫·麦卡里吗？对。那他是，他在《周六夜现场》做什么？他在那儿当了大约五年编剧兼导演。哦，不错。制作数码短片。你们是在那儿认识的？我在那儿认识他的，对。
But we had a bunch of mutual friends, so, yeah. So great, I love that. I feel like I was there that week too, although you've probably hosted a few times. I remember being there once when you were hosting, and was like, oh, she's so much better. I hold on. I'm gonna host on December 2nd. I get teched by five timers jacket. Oh, I'm so excited. I can't even stand it. I'm like, I'm freaking out. You're so good at it. That's really, really cool. Wait, so Emma, you and Dave married in
不过我们有一群共同的朋友，所以，是的。太棒了，我喜欢这样。我觉得我也在那周去过，虽然你可能主持过好几次。我记得有一次你在主持的时候我在那儿，当时我就想，哦，她做得好太多了。等等。我将在12月2日主持。我拿到了“五次俱乐部”的夹克。哦，我太兴奋了。我简直不敢相信。我简直，我快疯了。你太擅长这个了。这真的很酷。等等，艾玛，你和戴夫是在
the pandemic. And was that just because it was planned that way and you just kept it or you're like, you know what, let's just do this now. You were waiting for a pandemic. Were you, did you guys say you wanted to get married, but let's wait for a pandemic, did I? We're just trying to fad a little bit on this invite list. Yeah. You know, the week that I got married, I did open a refrigerator and the handle broke off and I got a plug. Oh my god. Oh my god. You need a hell of it. And that's where it stops. You know, I do need a refrigerator and the handle broke off and I got a plug. Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God.
疫情期间结婚的。那是原本就计划好的，所以你们就照办了，还是说你们觉得，你知道吗，我们现在就办吧。你们一直在等疫情吗？是不是你们俩说想结婚，但让我们等一场疫情再结，我是这么说的吗？我们只是想在这份邀请名单上稍微精简一点。对。你知道的，我结婚的那周，我确实打开过冰箱，然后把手柄拽断了，我还拿了个插头。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。你真需要戴个头盔。这就说得通了。你知道，我确实需要一个冰箱，而且把手断了，我还拿了个插头。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
You need a helmet. You know, I do need a helmet. Oh my God. I need a helmet and extensive wear. You got this new show with Nathan Field, or I want to skip ahead. I know she's your guest. Oh, yeah. That looks really...
你真需要个头盔。你知道，我确实需要个头盔。哦，天哪。我需要一个头盔和广泛的磨损。你有这个和内森·菲尔德合作的新节目，或者我想跳过前面。我知道她是你的嘉宾。哦，对。那看起来真的……
I know she's your guest, but I'll take this one. But I'll say, it looks really fun. First of all, he's great and not just because he's Canadian, he's super funny. You're super funny. And when I first saw the ad for it, I was like, these motherfuckers, and then they got one of those safties in there. Yeah, that's true. Put a wig on him.
我知道她是你的嘉宾，但这集我来接。不过我要说，这看起来真的很有趣。首先，他很棒，不仅因为他是加拿大人，他超级搞笑。你超级搞笑。当我第一次看到它的广告时，我心想，这群王八蛋，然后他们里面居然有个萨夫迪。对，那倒也是。给他戴个假发。
Then the three took the boom out of his hand and said, go, this is like a fucking, this is like a fucking talent explosion happening in one thing. I'm so goddamn excited for this thing. I mean, I'm so excited for this. It's a wild ride. Now, well, tell us about how did that come to you to your orbit? Nathan, so Nathan and I have known each other through Dave
然后这三个人把吊杆从他手里拿走，说，开始，这就像一个他妈的，这就像一个他妈的天才大爆发正在发生。我为这事兴奋得要命。我是说，我为这兴奋极了。这是一次疯狂的旅程。现在，那么，跟我们讲讲这个是怎么进入你的视野的？内森，内森和我通过戴夫认识
and Dave's best friend Kyle Mooney have been with friends. I love how many years. And they've been best friends since they were nine years old. So yeah, and so Nathan, uh, new David and Kyle well, and I got to know Nathan, uh, for a couple years.
还有戴夫最好的朋友凯尔·穆尼一直是朋友。我喜欢，多少年了。他们从九岁起就是最好的朋友了。所以，是的，内森，嗯，很了解大卫和凯尔，我认识内森，嗯，也有好几年了。
And then I think in 2020, 2019, maybe, uh, Nathan called me and said that he and Benny Safdie had come up with this kind of loose idea for a show based on something that Nathan had really experienced where someone had said that they cursed him in a moment. And he was like, this probably isn't true, but he found that it haunted him. Sure. And they started coming up with this sort of premise of what would happen if you're kind of going about your life and they had this idea for this couple who is trying to create their own HGTV show.
然后我想大概在2020年，2019年吧，内森打电话给我，说他和本尼·萨夫迪想出了一个关于节目的松散创意，灵感来自于内森经历过的一件事：有人在某个时刻说他们诅咒了他。他当时想，这可能不是真的，但他发现这件事一直萦绕在他心头。确实。然后他们开始构思这样一个前提：如果你正在过自己的生活会发生什么？他们针对一对试图制作自己的HGTV节目的夫妇有了这个想法。
But early on, the husband, a little girl says, I curse you. And if that hangs over the premise of this whole show and how that evolves and kind of makes them go crazy, whether it's real or not. And it just sort of spiraled out from there and became this very intense show. It's really, it is a comedy, but it's kind of not a comedy. Kind of dark. Yeah. Yeah. It's very, yeah, there's a lot going on there. So it was, you know, it was a blast.
但在早期，丈夫遇到了一个小女孩，小女孩说：“我诅咒你。”这个情节一直悬在这个节目的整个前提之上，它是如何发展的，又是如何让他们抓狂的，不管这是真是假。然后事情就从那里开始急转直下，变成了一个非常激烈的节目。这真的，它是一部喜剧，但又有点不算喜剧。有点黑暗。对。对。非常，对，里面有很多事情在发生。所以，你知道，这真是太棒了。
And we were in New Mexico for like half of last year shooting that. And say the title again? The curse. Yeah, the curse. I see posters for it everyone. And say the title one more time. And what is it over the third time?
我们去年有一半时间都在新墨西哥州拍摄这个。再把片名说一遍？《诅咒》。对，《诅咒》。我到处都能看到它的海报。再把片名说一遍。第三遍到底叫什么？
I'm so the curse. I want to talk about poor things too, which is a movie that you have come in. The way you're the most man. I am. I'm going to go see it this week. You are? Yeah.
我是说《诅咒》。我还想聊聊《可怜的东西》，这也是你主演的一部电影。你看你的表情。我是。我这周就要去看它。是吗？对。
I can't wait. Where are you going to see it? I'm seeing it. It's one of the screen, because I'm going, I'm going to be at those. Yeah. I'll see you there. I just got a text for it.
我等不及了。你要去哪里看？我要去看。在某家影院，因为我要去，我要去那些地方。对。到时候见。我刚收到关于它的短信。
Yeah. Oh, great. Was it me texting you to come with those? I was here. Do you go by Emma Stone? No. I'll see you there. I just got a text for it. Yeah. Oh, great. Was it me texting you to come with us? I was here. Where do you go by Emma Stone? Oh, shit. It is.
哦，太棒了。是我发短信叫你一起去的吗？我当时在这儿。你平时用艾玛·斯通这个名字吗？不。到时候见。我刚收到关于它的短信。对。哦，太棒了。是我发短信叫你一起去的吗？我当时在这儿。你平时用艾玛·斯通这个名字吗？哦，操。是的。
Yeah. This is the second project with Yorgos. Yes. It was technically the third because we made a short film at the beginning of 2020. And then so, but it was, it was. Yeah, it was, yeah. It was a second full one.
对。这是和欧格斯的第二个项目。是的。严格来说是第三个，因为我们在2020年初拍过一部短片。然后所以，但它是，它是。对，它是，对。这是第二部完整的长片。
He's so brilliant. Amazing. We made another one in the meantime. We made another really new Orleans last year. No, really? We did with with with Willem. With Willem. Yeah, Willem's the poor things.
他太才华横溢了。太棒了。我们在那期间又拍了一部。我们去年在纽奥良又拍了一部非常新的作品。真的吗？我们和威廉一起拍的。和威廉。对，威廉演了《可怜的东西》。
Yeah, yeah, we're doing two together. And so for my, for my sister, Tracy, Yara Gostid, the favorite, the lobster, just a bunch of great kill sacred deer. It's a dog too, so which is... Yeah, it's a poor thing. So did you develop it? Did you find it like you're just getting off for like how did that go?
对，对，我们俩合作了两次。所以对于我的，对于我妹妹特蕾西，欧格斯导演的作品还有《宠儿》、《龙虾》，还有一堆像《圣鹿之死》那样的大作。还有一部也是，所以……对，就是《可怜的东西》。所以这是你们自己开发的吗？你是自己找到这个项目还是别人找上门的，这过程是怎样的？
So Yorgos and I did the favorite in 2017 and right as we were wrapping up the favorite. He told me about this book that he and Tony McNamara, who was the writer of the favorite, had optioned and they were working on adapting. And he just told me the premise of it, and I was like, I beg of you, I have to do this with you. And so for the next few years, we worked on things and started kind of putting it all together. And any ask me to be a producer
我和欧格斯在2017年合作了《宠儿》，就在我们快要完成《宠儿》的时候。他跟我讲了一本书，他和《宠儿》的编剧托尼·麦克纳马拉已经买下了版权，并正在着手改编。他把故事的大纲跟我讲了一下，我当时就说，我求求你了，我必须和你一起拍这部电影。所以在接下来的几年里，我们一直在推进这事，开始把一切筹备起来。而且他还让我当制片人
on it, which was amazing. And so we kind of like assembled this team and then at the end of 2021, why do I keep saying all the dates? Yeah, I don't know. Because you're like, well, you have incredible recall on dates. I do everything by date. So really? Month and year, yeah.
这太棒了。所以我们就像这样组建了这个团队，然后到了2021年底，我为什么一直提这些日期？对，我不知道。因为你就像，好吧，你对日期的记忆力太惊人了。我所有事都按日期记。真的吗？月份和年份，对。
You too. Everybody's birthdays. Do you forget a birthday? Can you forget a birthday once a year? I can forget a birthday, but if you? Month and year, yeah, yeah. You too. Everybody's birthdays. Do you forget a birthday? Oh, yeah. Can you forget a birthday once a year? I can forget a birthday, but if you say like, hey, like, I can say like, oh, yeah, like, it was that time of year or that year. It was this month, the March of 2023.
你也是。每个人的生日。你会忘掉生日吗？一年会忘掉一次生日吗？我可能会忘掉一个生日，但如果你？月份和年份，对，对。你也是。每个人的生日。你会忘掉生日吗？哦，对。一年会忘掉一次生日吗？我可能会忘掉一个生日，但如果你说，嘿，比如，我可以这么说，哦，对，比如，那是当年的那个时候或是那一年。就是这个月，2023年3月。
The March of 2023, he knows a difference between April of 21 and March of 24. But maybe I functioned similarly. Yeah, I'm busy. But anyway, so. Anyway, so we made it two years ago, and yeah, it's just, it's probably my favorite, my favorite thing I've ever gotten to do. Really? Yeah.
2023年3月，他分得清2021年4月和2024年3月的区别。不过也许我的运作方式也差不多。对，我很忙。不过总之，所以。总之，所以我们两年前拍了它，对，这可能是我做过的最喜欢，最喜欢的事了。真的吗？对。
Wait, so with, you work all the time constantly, it seems like, which is great, and everybody can't get enough of you. Oh. So when you go from, when you go from set to set, other than your child, do you have something? How do you set it up so it's home? Or how do you set it up so it feels like, all right, I need to have at least this, this,
等等，那么，你一直在工作，不断地工作，看起来是这样的，这很棒，而且大家都对你百看不厌。哦。所以当你从，当你从一个片场到另一个片场时，除了你的孩子，你还有什么吗？你如何布置才能让它有家的感觉？或者你如何布置才能觉得，好吧，我至少需要这个，这个，
this in my trailer or this, this, this with me. What a fun question. I'll tell you, I'll tell you three things that always keep me company, no matter where I am. Coke? App. Sorry.
这个在我的房车里，或者这个，这个，这个和我在一起。多么有趣的问题。我来告诉你，我来告诉你三样无论我在哪里都能一直陪伴我的东西。可乐？应用程序。抱歉。
Big plate of Coke. Just the idea, you gotta get through it. I think I'm sad with the idea that I'm on Coke just because I'm on cold medicine. I'm chasing. Go with it. You know, just suffer in through this on cold medicine. She's here on a audition. I know, I have a broken foot.
一大盘可乐。就是那个概念，你得熬过去。我觉得我提到可乐是因为我正在吃感冒药。我在追。继续。你知道，就是靠着感冒药硬挺过去。她是来试镜的。我知道，我脚骨折了。
I can't believe it. Broken foot? I'm near a dance. I know, I can't believe it. No, apples and peanut butter. Really? Really? Every day for a snack, I have apples and peanut butter. Every day I have a Starbucks coffee.
我真不敢相信。脚骨折了？我得去跳舞。我知道，我真不敢相信。不，苹果和花生酱。真的吗？真的吗？我每天的零食都是苹果和花生酱。我每天都要喝一杯星巴克的咖啡。
Doesn't matter where I am. Could be in the greatest coffee places in the world. You're up wherever. Doesn't matter. Find a Starbucks. And what's your choice? A coconut mist. Coconut mist up wherever, doesn't matter. Find a Starbucks. And what's your choice? A coconut misto.
不管我在哪里。可以是在世界上最棒的咖啡店。不管你在哪儿。都无所谓。找一家星巴克。你的选择是什么？椰奶美士朵。不管你在哪儿，都无所谓。找一家星巴克。你的选择是什么？椰奶美士朵。
Oh. Coconut misto. No, a fairist misto. What is it? A coconut what? Listen, they make you say misto. But you know the Starbucks lingo where they make you say these things.
哦。椰奶美士朵。不，是黑咖啡美士朵。是什么？椰奶什么？听着，他们让你叫美士朵。但你知道星巴克的行话，他们会让你这么叫。
It's a venti coffee, just a regular filter coffee, a drip coffee, a large, with steamed coconut milk. Okay. And that's the meastow part? That's the meastow. That's what makes it a meastow. So that's not a latte. It's not a latte, no, because it's not espresso.
就是一杯中杯咖啡，普通的滤泡咖啡，滴漏咖啡，大杯的，加蒸椰奶。好的。这就是美士朵的部分？这就是美士朵。这就是让它成为美士朵的原因。所以这不是拿铁。这不是拿铁，不，因为里面没有浓缩咖啡。
So you have apple, by the way, I have peanut butter and rice cakes, always. Everyday? Well, that's my treat. That's my snack. That's your treat? Yeah, that's my snack. I can feel like it'll be enough. Peanut butter and rice cake? Well, I love that. That's a my treat. That's my snack. That's your treat? Yeah, that's my snack. I can feel like in a minute after.
所以你有苹果，顺便说一句，我有花生酱和年糕，一直都有。每天？嗯，那是我的犒赏。那是我的零食。那是你的犒赏？对，那我的零食。我觉得这已经够了。花生酱配年糕？嗯，我喜欢那个。那是我的犒赏。那是我的零食。那是你的犒赏？对，那是我的零食。我觉得过一会儿。
Peanut butter and rice cake? I love that. That's a healthy treat. It's not like you go and get all the twizzlers from the... Why don't you guys go with just the apple or just the rice cake? Why do you need to spread all the fatty peanut butter? Peanut butter gives you a little hit of protein and this big hit of joy. I like the peanut butter with the apples.
花生酱配年糕？我喜欢那个。那是健康的犒赏。不像你去买一堆……你们俩为什么不直接吃苹果或年糕呢？为什么非要抹那么多高脂肪的花生酱？花生酱能给你提供一点蛋白质和巨大的快乐。我喜欢花生酱配苹果。
Enjoy. Sean explain for, not for Jason, but for Jason what joy is. It's another kind of peanut butter. Not for. No, that's giffy. Emma, like when I you were so fucking phenomenal in the favor and you won for the favorite, right? No. She did. No. No. She was fantastic though. Thank you so much. She dominated. Wait, but what was that? You wanted nomination is what I meant. Did you really not win? I can't remember.
好好享受。肖恩解释一下，不是为杰森解释，而是为杰森解释什么是快乐。那是另一种花生酱。不是为了。不，那是吉夫牌。艾玛，当我在《宠儿》里的表现太他妈惊艳了，你凭《宠儿》获奖了吧？没有。她得过。没有。没有。不过她棒极了。非常感谢。她统治了全场。等等，但那是怎么回事？你是说你获得了提名。你真的没得奖吗？我不记得了。
You did win. Not for the, not for the favorite. No. What, which one did you win for? Lollol. Oh, that's right. Lollol. So I'm not going to be too.
你确实得奖了。不是因为，不是因为《宠儿》。没有。那你凭哪部得的奖？《爱乐之城》。哦，对的。《爱乐之城》。所以我不会太。
You're so good. I'm not going to be too. You're so good. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. I'm not going to be too. God, you're so pretty good. It's a totally embarrassing thing to have to sit here and say. No. Well, I've heard that one.
你太棒了。我不会太。你太棒了。我不会太。我不会太。我不会太。我不会太。我不会太。我不会太。我不会太。我不会太。天哪，你太棒了。坐在这里说这些真的是一件很尴尬的事。不。好吧，我听说过那个。
No, I want to know. I asked. I want to know everything. But wait, the favorite was yours too. My mom says I'm always a winner. Yeah, and always her favorite. Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
不，我想知道。我问了。我想知道一切。不过等等，《宠儿》也是你的。我妈妈说我永远是赢家。对，而且永远是她的最爱。对，没错。没错。
But was that because when I was seeing that movie, when I watched that movie, I was like, oh my God, this just looks like a colossal amount of work that movie, the favorite. Like, it just looks so grand and so massive. And then- That just gives a lot of it was in that fish I lens. That's what makes it look so grand. All right.
但这难道是因为当我看到那部电影时，当我看完那部电影，我想，哦，天哪，那部电影的工作量简直太巨大了，《宠儿》。就像，看起来那么宏大，那么浩大。然后- 那很大程度上是因为用了那种鱼眼镜头。那才是它看起来如此宏大的原因。好吧。
You know what I mean? That's a little trick of the trade. That was in England, yes. That was in England. And Lala Land was here in Los Angeles. In LA, yes. The favorite, favorite. It'sala Land was here in Los Angeles. In LA, yes. A favorite, favorite. Such a good movie.
你知道我的意思吗？那是行业里的小技巧。那是在英格兰拍的，对。那是在英格兰。而《爱乐之城》是在洛杉矶这里。在洛杉矶，对。《宠儿》，《宠儿》。真是一部好电影。
I just wanted to go. Apart from the work that these guys were so tired, but I, that movie was so good. I must tell you. No. We'll be right back. Smart List fans, listen up. Have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show, Add Free, and one week early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership?
我只想说。除了这些家伙工作得太累之外，那部电影真是太棒了。我必须告诉你。不。Smartless的粉丝们，注意听啦。你们听说过可以用Prime会员资格在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上免费且提前一周收听这个节目的单集吗？
That's right, all your favorite smart list episodes can be heard on Amazon Music, Add Free, and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all, you can listen to your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad Dates and Just Jack and Will, Early and Add Free too. They also have favorites like the daily, pardon my take and up first, all without any ads. You know what this means?
没错，你所有最喜欢的Smartless单集都可以在亚马逊音乐上无广告收听，而且你总是能第一批听到我们的新单集，这样你就可以在朋友面前炫耀了。不仅如此，你还可以收听其他你喜爱的节目，比如，我不知道，比如《糟糕的约会》和《威尔和格蕾丝》，同样可以提前且无广告收听。他们还有像《每日新闻》、《Pardon My Take》和《Up First》等热门节目，全部都没有广告。你知道这意味着什么吗？
Uninterrupted listening, so no more cliff hangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcasts, so we know they definitely have something for you. And it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com, slash smartless. That's Amazon.com slash smartless, or download the Amazon Music app.
不间断收听，再也没有悬念了。亚马逊音乐提供最多无广告的顶级播客，所以我们知道他们绝对有适合你的内容。而且这已经包含在你的Prime会员资格中了。要立即收听，你只需访问Amazon.com斜杠smartless。也就是Amazon.com斜杠smartless，或者下载亚马逊音乐应用程序。
It's just that easy. This episode has brought to you in part by Rocket Money. Did you know over 80% of people have subscriptions they've forgotten about? It's too easy to subscribe to a free trial of something and then completely forget about it once you stop using it right as the monthly charges start rolling in. That's why Rocket Money is here. Rocket Money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors your spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place.
就是这么简单。本集部分内容由Rocket Money赞助播出。你知道超过80%的人都有他们已经忘掉的订阅服务吗？人们太容易去订阅某样东西的免费试用，然后在停止使用后将其完全忘得精光，直到每月的扣款开始滚滚而来。这就是Rocket Money存在的原因。Rocket Money是一款个人理财应用程序，它可以在一个地方帮你找到并取消你不需要的订阅，监控你的支出，并帮助你降低账单。
With Rocket Money you can easily cancel the ones you don't want with just the press of a button. No more long hold times or annoying emails with customer service, Rocket Money does all the work for you. Rocket Money can even negotiate to lower your bills view by up to 20%. All you have to do is take a picture of your bill and Rocket Money takes care of the rest. Rocket Money also lets you monitor all your expenses in one place. Recommends custom budgets based on your past spending, and they'll even send you notifications
通过Rocket Money，只需按一下按钮，你就可以轻松取消那些你不需要的订阅。再也不用忍受长时间的等待或给客服发烦人的电子邮件了，Rocket Money为你完成所有工作。Rocket Money甚至可以通过谈判将你的账单费用降低多达20%。你所需要做的就是拍下你的账单照片，剩下的就交给Rocket Money来处理。Rocket Money还允许你在一个地方监控所有的费用。根据你过去的消费习惯推荐定制预算，甚至会在你达到消费限额时向你发送通知
when you reach your spending limits. Isn't that cool? With over 5 million users and counting, RocketMoney has helped save its customers in average of $720 a year, and $1 billion in total savings so far. Stop wasting money on things you don't use. Cancel your unwanted subscriptions,
是不是很酷？拥有超过500万及更多的用户，Rocket Money已经帮助其客户平均每年节省720美元，迄今为止总共节省了10亿美元。不要再把钱浪费在你不使用的东西上了。取消你不需要的订阅，
and manage your money the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless, rocketmoney.com slash smartless. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless, rocketmoney.com slash smartless. This episode is brought to you in part by Macy's. If you're feeling the holiday time crunch get all the gift in-spot using Macy's gift finder. Navigate through the holiday hustle with ease
用简单的方式管理你的资金，访问rocketmoney.com斜杠smartless。也就是rocketmoney.com斜杠smartless，rocketmoney.com斜杠smartless。这就是rocketmoney.com斜杠smartless，rocketmoney.com斜杠smartless。本集部分内容由Macy's梅西百货赞助播出。如果你正赶上节日的忙碌关头，使用Macy's的礼物查找器（Gift Finder）轻松搞定所有送礼灵感。利用他们实用的搜索选项（例如按价格购物），
using their helpful search options like Shop by Price. You can shop gifts by budget, whether it's $25, $50 or Lux. Shop by gift lists. Discover curated unique lists for all the personalities in your life. Is your loved one a spa day enthusiast and ad bent calendar fan? A big sports fan, Macy says, God, you covered. You can even find curated gift lists from your fabed influencers. Shop by category. Explore top picks and beauty fragrances, jewelry and watches, handbags and accessories, and more. And that's not all.
轻松穿梭于节日的喧嚣之中。你可以按预算购买礼物，无论是25美元、50美元还是奢华款。按礼品清单购买。为生活中的各种性格寻找精选的独家清单。你爱的人是水疗日爱好者还是倒计时日历迷？是超级体育迷，梅西百货都能满足你。你甚至可以找到来自你最喜欢的网红的精选礼品清单。按类别购物。探索美妆香水、珠宝手表、手袋配饰等的精选好物。还不止这些。
You'll find packaged and ready to give gifts, top rated customer favorites, secret Santa inspiration, and the light, full stocking stuffers. So why stress? Head to macy's.com slash gift finder and uncover the perfect presence for everyone on your list. This holiday season
你会找到打包好随时可送的礼物、获得最高评价的顾客最爱、秘密圣诞老人灵感以及令人愉悦的袜子填充小礼物。所以为什么要压力山大呢？前往macy's.com斜杠gift finder，为你名单上的每个人发掘完美的礼物。这个假日季
make it memorable with Macy's. And now back to the show. Was that one of the hardest things you've ever done that, but what's the hardest one you've ever done? Oh God. Physically, emotionally, both whatever. Law and the land had a bunch of stuff in there. Oh, yeah. You're learning a thing. The hardest thing I've ever done was on stage. Yeah. By far.
让它因梅西百货而难忘。现在回到节目中。那是你做过最艰难的事情之一吗，但你做过最艰难的是哪一个？哦，天哪。身体上，情感上，无论是哪种。拍《爱乐之城》时有很多那种内容。哦，对。你得学一门手艺。我做过最艰难的事情是在舞台上。对。遥遥领先。
Sean loves stage stories. I do, you know I do. Well, I've only done one professional stage show. What went wrong? Like 10 years ago. Oh, you want to, what went wrong, Sean? I want to, like, a bad theater story. Well, but here's, I did Cabaret.
肖恩喜欢舞台故事。我知道你喜欢。好吧，我只演过一次专业舞台剧。哪里出错了？大概10年前。哦，你想知道哪里出错了，肖恩？我想听听，比如一个糟糕的剧院故事。好吧，事情是这样的，我演了《歌厅》。
And I only did it for three and a half months, which is so short by stage terms. But enough. I thought, I truly going into it. I was so beyond excited. It was probably the greatest experience of my life for the same reason. And I was like, oh, you just do it at night.
我只演了三个半月，按舞台标准来说这时间太短了。但也够受的了。我当时想，老实说在加入之前。我兴奋得无以复加。这可能是我一生中最棒的经历，出于同样的原因。我当时想，哦，你只需要在晚上演。
And then you do two shows a day on Wednesday, and you do two on Saturdays. And then you do two shows a day on Wednesday, and you do two on Saturday, and it's just, and then you're home, and you're just, your entire life is eaten. And it is so hard, you have to live like a monk. Like, there's nothing, at least I did, because I lose my voice and I just sing, and it was like, I've never experienced
然后你周三演两场，周六演两场。然后你周三演两场，周六演两场，就只是，然后你回家，你的整个生活都被占满了。而且这太难了，你必须像个苦行僧一样生活。就像，什么都没有，至少我是这样的，因为我会失去嗓音，而且我一直在唱歌，就好像，我从未经历过
something that, that physically, taxing as an actor. It was, it was unreal. I'm sure. taxing as an actor. Yeah, I'm sure I'm sure. And when you when you put to do anything go massively wrong, do you have like any kind of night where you just like, oh, shit, my voice nothing came out when I say. Oh, oh, yeah, I mean, I would have to take steroids multiple times. Like, no, yeah, no heart attacks in the house.
作为演员，在体力上如此吃力的事。这简直，简直不真实。我敢肯定。在体力上如此吃力。是的，我敢肯定，我敢肯定。当你要去做任何事情时，有没有出现过大规模出问题的情况？你有没有过这样的夜晚，比如，哦，操，我的声音，我说话时什么也发不出声音。哦，哦，是的，我的意思是，我不得不多次注射类固醇。不，是的，家里没有心脏病发作。
Thank God, but that's there are a lot of those stories. But that no, I just to in the house. Thank God, but that's there are a lot of those stories, but no I Just to add to my you know things that are wrong with me. I'm extremely blind blind blind is about okay and I wear a context for that and They both popped out of my eyes while I was singing maybe this time And there's and it cuts a really been reaching for a note It cuts. Yeah, I'm always reaching for those notes as I'm not a singer per se and the and the lights went dark And you have to you know go off in the in the blackout and I couldn't see a
谢天谢地，不过这种故事有很多。但是没有，我只是要在家里。谢天谢地，不过那有很多这种故事，但是不，我只是要再加上我（你知道的）我身上不对劲的地方。我极其眼盲，眼盲，盲得差不多了，好吧。我为此戴隐形眼镜。当我唱《也许此时》时，它们双双从我眼里蹦了出来。而且有，而且这真的需要去够一个音符。它中断了。对，我总是在努力去够那些音符，因为我本身不是歌手，而且灯光变暗了。
Thing in the world and I just went like slammed it. It was terrible. That getting off stage, not being able to see it all is. That's terrifying. And then couldn't find the contacts, right? They were on the floor. Couldn't find it. But I know I always bring spares. I have to travel with spares.
你必须，你知道，在黑暗中退场，我当时什么也看不见。
Yeah. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important.
世界上的任何东西，我当时就砰的一声撞了上去。太糟糕了。下台后什么也看不见，这感觉太可怕了。然后找不到隐形眼镜了，对吧？它们掉在地上了。找不到。但我知道我总是带备用隐形眼镜。我出门必须带备用隐形眼镜。
It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. It's very important. Yeah, all of it gives me so much anxiety. But when you... I always had a fear shot of getting hiccups on stage. Yeah, and that too. Oh my God, that's a great fear. Have you had hiccups on stage? No, but I had one thing where I had allergies
这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。
and I could feel the post nasal dripping the back. And it was right before I had a sing, what do you get when you fall in love? You know, with the Christmas sun. Yeah, and I was literally like, Oh no. Like forever. Oh, God.
这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。这非常重要。是的，这一切都让我感到无比焦虑。但是当你……肖恩，我一直有一种恐惧，就是在舞台上打嗝。是的，那个也是。哦，天哪，这真是一个可怕的恐惧。你在舞台上打过嗝吗？没有，但我有过一次，我当时过敏。
It was the worst panic tears because I couldn't cough, but I had to act like I was everything. It's still, I have a million. It's just, okay, I'm about to tell you guys something that I think that you're not gonna enjoy. I know Jason's not gonna enjoy this. Oh no.
我能感觉到鼻涕倒流到喉咙后面。就在我要唱歌之前，歌词是“当你坠入爱河时你会得到什么？”你知道，伴随着圣诞节的阳光。对，我当时简直就像是，“哦不。”就像永远一样。哦，天哪。
What do you do when you get, I'm gonna ask you guys, I'm gonna go around to the panel here. What do you guys do when you get the hiccups? Do you have like a sure fire? I don't have one. I have a cure. I have a cure.
那是最糟糕的恐慌泪水，因为我不能咳嗽，但我必须装作一切正常。这还是，我有一百万个。好吧，我正要告诉你们一件事，我觉得你们不会喜欢。我知道杰森不会喜欢这个。哦不。
I have a cure, but people tell me that I'm wrong, but if not if you do it, right, okay? Here's the thing. Yeah, you don't scream at people. This is the saw. Pull your arm up above your head. Just take one arm. Put it up above your head.
你们在打嗝时会怎么做，我要问问你们，我要问问这里的嘉宾。你们在打嗝时会怎么做？你们有什么万无一失的秘诀吗？我没有。我有一个治愈方法。我有一个治愈方法。
Well, just because I'm right handed, so if you're left handed, you can do it. Drivers don't do this. You take your, don't do it if you're driving. Now, take water, and I'm talking like tiny sips, you go, swallow, swallow, swallow, swallow, as you lower your arm slowly. Well, nothing's gonna happen,
我有一个治愈方法，但人们告诉我我是错的，除非你做对了，对吧？事情是这样的。对，你别对人大喊大叫。这是诀窍。把你的手臂举过头顶。只用举起一只手臂。把它举过头顶。
because look at all of this. Is that a mistake? We're all chewing it. Why would you practice it? Listeners, we're all doing it. We're practicing. I'm telling you, it is 100% of the time. I feel incredible.
好吧，因为我是右利手，所以如果你是左利手也可以这么做。开车的人别这么做。现在，拿一杯水，我说的是一小口一小口地喝，你要说，吞咽，吞咽，吞咽，吞咽，同时慢慢放下你的手臂。好吧，什么都不会发生，
If you do it correctly. I feel amazing. What do you guys do? You're Sean or J. I, I, I, nothing. I, I, I wish I had something. I don't think. I think a deep breath.
因为看看这一切。这是个错误吗？我们都在嚼着东西。你们为什么要练习这个？听众们，我们都在做。我们在练习。我向你们保证，这有100%的成功率。我感觉好极了。
And, and I kind of let it feel it kind of go away and then I take water while I'm holding my breath. It seems to work. I've never told anybody this. This is absolutely true, and I can't believe I'm telling it. I'm ready. Anytime I get the hiccups,
如果你做得正确的话。我感觉太棒了。你们怎么做？肖恩或者J。我，我，我，什么都不做。我，我，我希望我有什么方法。我不这么认为。我觉得深吸一口气。
and I remember one time vividly, years ago our buddy Edgar Wright we did this thing called Don't, it was like a fake movie trailer between, there's a double bill, like a Robert Rodriguez film, whatever, and he made this fake trailer and I did the voice for it anyway. I remember going to record the trailer voice
然后，我让它感觉自己慢慢消失，接着我一边屏住呼吸一边喝水。这似乎挺管用的。我从来没跟任何人说过这个。这绝对是真的，我简直不敢相信我在说这个。我准备好了。每当我打嗝的时候。
because I'd do it. Don't even breathe, don't even blah, blah, blah, blah. I did this whole thing, right? I was in the West Village at this recording place. And doing the thing and I had a soda, I think, and I got the hiccups because I was taking in so much air. And I was like, what the fuck? This is where I learned it.
我清楚地记得有一次，很多年前，我们的好友埃德加·赖特，我们做了一个叫《别》的东西，那是一个假的电影预告片，在罗伯特·罗德里格斯的电影双片连映之间，诸如此类的东西，他制作了这个假的预告片，我为它配了音。总之，我记得去录制预告片的配音。
And I was like, just give me a second, I just got to, because I'm like, hiccuping on, you know, trying to record. And I go into the bathroom. Uh-oh. And I stick my finger down my throat, and I make myself gag and throw up a little bit. Yeah. Yeah. Gone. I get it. I came back out and I finished and that's what I do every time when I get
因为我要做这个。别呼吸，甚至别，巴拉巴拉巴拉。我做了整个过程，对吧？我在西村的这个录音地方。做着这件事，我喝了苏打水，我想，然后我开始打嗝，因为我吸入了太多的空气。我当时想，他妈的怎么回事？这就是我学会这个的地方。
the hiccups now I go, excuse me. I get it. That is just. We just got it. There's a better way, Will. I don't know. It works. Do you do you fully throw up or do you gag? It depends on where I'm at. You know. I hate hiccups. I will make myself. Wait, but this was, were you just gambling that this would work? Or is this something you'd kind of read about? I was just gambling. I had no idea. And I just did it. Wow, that is.
然后我说，给我一秒钟，我必须，因为我在打嗝，你知道，试图录音。我走进了洗手间。哦哦。然后我把手指伸进喉咙里，让自己作呕并吐了一点出来。对。对。没了。我懂了。我走出来，完成了录音，这就是我每次打嗝时做的事。
Huh. I did not know that you have a tattoo on your arm or your wrist or somewhere. My wrist. I want to see. Very, very, very poorly done tattoo. Look at this. Now this was supposed to be, I just want you to understand. This was based off of the drawing
现在我说，失陪一下。我懂了。这简直是。我们刚刚知道了。威尔，有更好的办法。我不知道。这管用。你是真的吐出来还是只是作呕？这取决于我当时的情况。你知道。我讨厌打嗝。我会让自己。等等，但这，你是在赌这会有用吗？还是你从哪里读到过这种方法？我只是在赌。我根本不知道。我当时就这么做了。哇，那真是。
that was drawn with a pencil, okay. It looks like bird feet. Does that look like a pencil? Is it a cactus? It's bird feet and it bleeds out more and more every single year. I got a 13 years ago and it just keeps spreading. In 20 years, this is just going to be.
哈。我不知道你胳膊或手腕什么地方有个纹身。我的手腕。我想看看。非常非常非常拙劣的纹身。看这个。这个本应该是，我只是想让你明白。这是根据一个图纸来的。
What kind of half-assed tag do artists? Were you in a French prison or something? I went into just kind of a random tattoo place on 14th Street and I was, yes. Why didn't you consult with the sleeveless one? He could have hooked you up with a great tattoo artist. And now I've gone to, to good tattoo artist and said, can I get this lasered off and read down?
用铅笔画的图纸，好吧。这看起来像鸟爪。这看起来像铅笔画的吗？是个仙人掌吗？这是鸟爪，而且每年都在不断地晕开。我13年后纹的，它一直在扩散。再过20年，这就会变成。
And they were like, your skin is so thin there that it's probably just gonna look like your burn, like it might be worse. Oh really? So wait, so I don't know what to do. And your mom got the same one. My mom, my dad, my brother, I mean, the story behind it is so special,
艺术家这是什么半吊子水平？你当时是在法国监狱里还是怎么的？我只是走进了14街的一家随便的纹身店，然后，是的。你为什么不咨询一下那个不穿袖子的人？他可以给你介绍一个优秀的纹身师。现在我已经去过了。去过好的纹身师那里，问他们，我能把这个激光洗掉然后重纹吗？
but it was like, and theirs all look great, by the way. Because they all went to better tattoo people. And I'm the one who's covered up for work every day. And it's like raised up. It's really. Don't you hang out with Thoreau just a little bit? I know Thoreau. Yeah, so he could have hooked you up with somebody with maybe a better needle.
他们的反应是，你那里的皮肤太薄了，洗掉可能看起来就像烧伤一样，可能会更糟。哦真的吗？所以等等，所以我不知道该怎么办了。你妈妈也有同款。我妈妈，我爸爸，我哥哥，我的意思是，这背后的故事非常特别。
I didn't know him then. Yeah, yeah. could have hook you up with somebody with maybe a better. I didn't know him then. Yeah, yeah, this was 2010. I love that your whole family has it. And he thoughts on Justin. This was October of 2010, Will, you remember? I love that. I love that. By the way, I wasn't going to say it before, but you know, when we shot the rocker, it was
但就像是，顺便说一句，他们的纹身看起来都很好。因为他们都去找了更好的纹身师。而我却是那个每天工作时都要把纹身遮起来的人。而且它有点凸起。真的很。你难道不跟梭罗（Thore）稍微混在一起吗？我认识梭罗。对，所以他本可以给你介绍一个针法更好的人。
June of 2007. Okay. I know. I know, you know, I know you know, um, uh, that is, yeah, Jason brought up a good point. Any thoughts on Thoreau. And by the way, this is a safe, safe place. Anything hurtful that you can think of. Another assignment we're introducing. Well, you know, he, he suffers from eczema. There we go. Does he really? That's why it doesn't wear sleeves because he's proud. He wants to show it. That's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car.
我那时候不认识他。对，对。本可以给你介绍一个针法更好的人。我那时候不认识他。对，对，那是2010年。我喜欢你全家都有这个。对贾斯汀有什么看法。那是2010年10月，威尔，你还记得吗？我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。顺便说一句，我本来不想说的，但你知道，当我们拍《摇滚之神》的时候是
He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car.
2007年6月。好吧。我知道。我知道，你知道，我知道，嗯，嗯，那是，对，杰森提出了一个好观点。对梭罗有什么看法。顺便说一句，这是一个绝对安全的地方。你可以畅所欲言任何伤人的想法。我们要引入另一个任务。好吧，你知道，他，他患有湿疹。这就对了。他真的有吗？这就是他为什么不穿袖子的原因，因为他很骄傲。他想展示出来。他就像一个坐在车里的人。他就像一个坐在车里的人。他就像一个坐在车里的人。他就像一个坐在车里的人。
他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。
He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's like a man in a car. He's one. Someone take it off. He did. He did. He did. He did like an hour late. I guess he got an alert or something. Yeah, Kimmel knows how to like break into someone's Wikipedia page.
他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他就像个坐在车里的人。他是其中一个。有人把它撤下来。他照做了。他照做了。他照做了。他差不多迟了一个小时才照做。我猜他收到了什么提醒之类的。对，吉米尔知道怎么黑进别人的维基百科页面。
He put it there. The wrong person to know how to do it too. Yeah, I love that. Will you guys put something on my Wikipedia page? Don't put that one. Put something different. No, yeah, we'll put you in a frame. We're going to put cries when Justin threw orgasms. Please, please don't put that. It would be funny to see a long life. It would be funny though.
他把它放在那儿了。找错人来干这事了。对，我太喜欢这个了。你们能在我的维基百科页面上加点东西吗？别加那个。加点别的。不，我们会把你整得很惨。我们要写上“贾斯廷高潮时会哭”。求求你，千万别写那个。不过看一辈子这个挺搞笑的。挺搞笑的。
Can I ask you about early, early, because you have a brother, right? I have a younger brother. You close with your brother? You vary, yeah. Oh, that is in the business. This is the two of us. No, no, he works in like a tech company. And growing up, was he interested or no?
我能问你一些早期的事吗，因为你有个弟弟，对吧？我有一个弟弟。你跟弟弟关系好吗？看情况，对。哦，他是在这一行吗？就我们俩。不，不，他在一家科技公司工作。那他成长过程中对这行感兴趣吗，还是没有？
He was less like, I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
他不太……我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. Hello, is it your brother? Very, yeah. Oh, that is he in the business. This is the two of us. No, no, he works in like a tech company. And growing up, was he interested or no? He was like, you do that, I'm gonna go over here. Not at all, he played football. Yeah, where was home, where did you grow up? Scotty, Arizona. Where the poop, with the poop. Remember earlier, there was the same conversation.
我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。我不知道。嗨，那是你弟弟吗？很亲，对。哦，他在这一行吗？就我们俩。不，不，他在一家科技公司工作。那他成长过程中对这行感兴趣吗，还是没有？他就觉得，你干你的，我去这边。完全不，他踢足球。对，老家在哪，你在哪长大的？斯科茨代尔，亚利桑那州。那个全是便便的地方，全是便便。还记得刚才我们聊过这个吗？
Huh? Yeah, how long have you been talking to him? Remember from before, it was like 20. What did you say? What did you say? And good thoughts, good feelings about Arizona. Do you miss it out there? You still have family out there?
啊？对，你跟他聊多久了？记得之前大概是20世纪。你刚才说什么？你刚才说什么？对亚利桑那州有什么好感、好印象？你怀念那里吗？你家里人还在那边吗？
Yeah, I still have family out there. The thing about Arizona is it's so hot. It's so oppressively hot. Yeah. It's difficult to, you need to be built for that kind of heat. And I'm not. It's not a fun heat. No.
对，我家人还在那边。亚利桑那州的问题是太热了。热得让人喘不过气。对。很难适应，你得是个抗热体质才行。而我不是。那可不是什么好玩的炎热。不。
It's not a fun heat at all. It's like 120 degrees daily. Yeah, that's absolutely. And we're gonna, and I want to ask you this because we're gonna end on an industry business question. I love a business deal. I love the business deal. I love the business deal. I love a biz, a biz deal. I love the biz, a biz deal.
那根本不是什么好玩的炎热。每天温度大概有120华氏度。对，绝对是。我们要，我想问你这个，因为我们要以一个行业业务问题来结尾。我喜欢商业交易。我喜欢商业交易。我喜欢商业交易。我喜欢商业、商业交易。我喜欢商业、商业交易。
I love the biz, a biz deal. I love the heat, I love the buzz. Yeah. Yeah. When you, you know, a lot of people who win and Oscar like you did for Lollaland, they, you were amazing, so deserved. I love that movie, I loved you in it.
我喜欢商业、商业交易。我喜欢高温，我喜欢这种热闹。对。对。当你，你知道，很多像你一样凭《爱乐之城》赢得奥斯卡的人，你当时太棒了，实至名归。我很喜欢那部电影，我也很喜欢你在里面的表现。
Did you, a lot of people who win, sometimes it's known as the curse of death with some actors, but you first of all I should ask are you guys locked or before I give you these are you picture locked? Yeah, I'm on the land. Yeah, because you got the Oscar great, but a couple things were it me? And it's just tried a little harder. I got some, I got some notes. Yeah, I got some. I was gonna say, how did you, were you nervous? Did you have anxiety? You're like, oh my God, this is so great. I won the Oscar, but did you have, did you feel like,
你，很多获奖的人，有时候这对某些演员来说被称为死亡诅咒，不过首先我得问你们，你们定稿了吗？在我把这些交给你之前，你们画面锁定了？对，我在岛上。对，因为你得了奥斯卡，这很好，但有几件事……是我吗？这还得再努力一点。我有一些，我有一些意见。对，我有一些。我是想说，你当时怎么想的？你紧张吗？你有焦虑吗？你会想，天哪，这太棒了。我得了奥斯卡，但你有没有，你有没有觉得……
I don't know, a lot of the times some actors who win Oscars, you kind of don't see them for a lot, like years and years and years, were you, did you have anxiety about like crap I won now, people are sick of me? Nope. Sean, nobody felt that way. No, not that I was.
我不知道，很多时候有些赢得奥斯卡的演员，你会有好几年都看不到他们，你有过焦虑吗，比如，糟了我赢了，人们现在是不是看腻我了？没有。肖恩，根本没有人那种感觉。没有，至少我没有。
No, but just like, what kind of a psycho? Sean, I put that out there. Why do you, okay, so now? Sean, would you tell us how you feel? No, no, no, not Tony. Wow, okay. You're walking up your chest to get the Tony. Okay.
没有，只是觉得，这是什么神经病问题？肖恩，我把这话说出来了。你为什么，好吧，所以现在？肖恩，你要不要告诉我们你的感受？不，不，不，不是托尼。哇，好吧。你正走上台去拿托尼奖呢。好吧。
Sean, that's my list. I know how he feels about it. I'm so proud of him. I'm still. I'm still. I came out wrong. What I meant was that you have anxiety about, like, I'm not going to work. People think, like, oh, you made it. I left.
肖恩，那是我的名单。我知道他是怎么想的。我为他感到骄傲。我还。我还。我刚才说错话了。我的意思是，你会有那种焦虑吗，比如，我以后没工作了。人们会觉得，哦，你成功了。我离开了。
This was a very lucky situation because I met Yorgos while we were filming La La Land and I left the day after that Oscar is to go shoot the favorite. Oh, that's great. So it was kind of amazing because the next day I went right back to work and was back in... Did you have time to renegotiate your deal
这是一个非常幸运的情况，因为我在拍《爱乐之城》的时候遇到了欧格斯，拿完奥斯卡的第二天我就去拍《宠儿》了。哦，那太棒了。所以这简直太奇妙了，因为第二天我就马上回去工作，回到了……你有时间重新谈判你的片约吗
on your way to the location? Yes. So that was... I did delay my flight for a couple hours just to call. Just to call my lawyer. By the way, that was re did delay my flight for a couple hours just to call just to call my lawyer By the way, that was reopened just a salary portion new deal points that I'd love to no, but by the way, and that was a big complement How many great because you've been you've been nominated. I'm sure a million times for I think it's a million is a million Lots of great awards. Do you have do you have do you for a lot of great. I think it's a million. He's a million. Lots of great awards.
在去片场的路上？是的。所以那是……我确实把航班改签了几个小时，就为了打个电话。就为了给我的律师打电话。顺便说一句，那是重——确实把航班改签了几个小时，就为了打个电话，就为了给我的律师打电话。顺便说一句，那是重新谈了薪酬部分和新的交易条款，我很乐意——不，但是顺便说一句，那是一个巨大的赞美。多棒啊，因为你已经被，你肯定被提名过无数次了——我觉得有一百万次——有很多伟大的奖项。你有没有，你有没有为很多伟大的奖项——我觉得有一百万次——有很多伟大的奖项。
Do you have a bunch of great unused acceptance speeches? No, what? No? I bet you do. No, but you give some thoughts and respectful time and some thought to what you would say up there. You're not one of these in grades that would just, ah, if I win, I'll just go up there and wing it.
你是不是有一大堆没用上的获奖感言？没有，什么？没有？我打赌你肯定有。没有，不过你会花心思、怀着敬意去思考在上面说些什么。你可不是那种会临时发挥、想着“要是得了奖我就直接上去瞎编”的拿奖专业户。
I bet you've got some fun stuff that you said, I just, my dream is to have like a book, a coffee table book of people's unused acceptance speeches. That's a great idea. That's a really good idea. That's a really good idea. Yeah. That maybe you should, maybe you should start compiling. You have to be anonymous though, wouldn't it? Well, right? The people with the screen. Yeah, because I guess it would be, but then how do you do an anonymous acceptance speech?
我打赌你肯定准备了一些有趣的话，我说，我的梦想就是出一本书，一本专门收录人们没能发表的获奖感言的精装书。这主意真不错。这主意真的很好。这主意真的很好。对。也许你应该，也许你应该开始收集。不过得是匿名的吧，对吧？对吧？那些屏幕前的人。对，因为我猜应该是这样，但那样的话你怎么搞匿名的获奖感言呢？
Everyone would know who it was, like the people that are thinking. What were you gonna say for the rocker? Yeah. If you had gotten up there for the rocker, well, who would you think first? Probably just Will. Yeah, Will.
每个人都知道是谁写的，就像那些思考的人一样。你本来打算为那部摇滚电影说些什么？对。如果你当时上台去领奖的话，好吧，你第一个会感谢谁？大概就是威尔吧。对，威尔。
Oh, good. Thanks for being our guest today. I don't even know. Thanks for having me. No, but you think you got nominated for, you got nominated for Lola and what you won, you got nominated for the favorite. Favorite. You got nominated for...
哦，太好了。谢谢今天能来做我们的嘉宾。我甚至不知道。谢谢你们邀请我。不，不过你想你因……获得过提名，你因《爱乐之城》获得过提名，你赢了，你因《宠儿》获得过提名。《宠儿》。你因……获得过提名
Talent. The Birdman? Is it the Birdman? Yeah. Yes. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And you had to work with Galvanakis. Oh God, I know.
《天才》。《鸟人》？是《鸟人》吗？对。是的。哦，对，对，对，对。你还不得不和加利费纳基斯合作。天哪，我懂。
Oh, what a fucking... Is there a less talented guy in showbiz than Zach Alphanakis? You know, from your lips to God's ears. I know. I couldn't agree more. He was so, so sweet. That was, anyway, yeah, no, he really has this.
哦，真是个该死的……演艺圈里还有比扎克·阿利纳基斯更没天赋的家伙吗？你知道的，心想事成。我知道。我完全同意。他真的非常好。那是，不管怎样，是的，不，他真的有这个。
What are you gonna do for us tonight? And are you watching Golden Bachelor? No. What's Golden Bachelor? I love that answer. I love? No. What's Golden Bachelor? I love that answer. I love that answer. What is Golden Bachelor? It's a bachelor, but I don't need to know.
你今晚要为我们做点什么？你在看《黄金单身汉》吗？没有。《黄金单身汉》是什么？我喜欢这个回答。我喜欢？没有。《黄金单身汉》是什么？我喜欢这个回答。我喜欢这个回答。《黄金单身汉》是什么？它是个单身汉节目，但我不需要知道。
You should never know what it is, Emma Stone. This is why you are you. Because you don't know. I'm just out here breaking bones, getting sick. Not watching Golden Bachelor. Well, now I'm gonna look it up. You went through a phase. Sean went for a phrasaser as breaking bones, right?
你永远不该知道那是什么，艾玛·斯通。这就是为什么你是你。因为你不知道。我只是在外面骨折，生病。不看《黄金单身汉》。好吧，现在我要去查一下。你经历过一个阶段。肖恩经历过一个阶段，就是骨折，对吧？
Yeah. Early 20s, Chicago. Oh, God. Hey, Emma, cool it, all right? Okay, sorry, sorry about that. Sorry. Emma Stone, we're gonna let you go. We're gonna let you heal.
对。20岁出头，芝加哥。哦，天哪。嘿，艾玛，冷静点，好吗？好吧，抱歉，真抱歉。抱歉。艾玛·斯通，我们让你走。我们让你去养伤。
We're gonna let you get better. We're gonna make you feel better. I'm gonna send some soup over. You don't need to send anything. All right, good. It'll be okay, great. Yeah, I won't do that. I just saved myself a call to my assistant. So, thank you guys for having me.
我们让你好起来。我们会让你感觉好点。我让人送点汤过去。你不用送任何东西。好吧，很好。会好起来的，太棒了。对，我不会那样做的。我省得给助理打电话了。所以，谢谢你们邀请我。
I'm sorry I was such a, you know, what are you talking about? You're incredibly fast, Ellen. Huge, huge, huge fan. Huge fan. Very, very, very sweet. You're such a, you're a, you're a, you're a, you're a mega talent.
很抱歉我这么个，你知道的，你在说什么？你速度太快了，艾伦。巨大、巨大、巨大的粉丝。超级粉丝。非常、非常、非常贴心。你真是个，你是个，你是个，你是个，你是个天才。
Yeah, mega. Yeah. True, true. You guys, Emma, Emma Stone, you guys so much. So, you're having me. Yeah. All the best.
对，超级。对。真的，真的。你们，艾玛，艾玛·斯通，非常感谢你们。邀请我。对。祝一切都好。
Hey, hey, Emma, one thing, I want you to remember one thing. Yeah. And I hope you've lived by this credo. You can always say this to every any guy. If you want to be my lover, first you got to get with my friends. Will? If you want to be my lover.
嘿，嘿，艾玛，有一件事，我要你记住一件事。对。我希望你一直遵循这个信条。你总是可以对任何男生这么说。如果你想成为我的男友，首先你得搞定我的朋友。威尔？如果你想成为我的男友。
Okay, got to get with my friends. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much. I will take that with me. Okay, I got it. You're not knowing that that was the Spice Girls Lyrics. Well, imagine one of the more painful things.
好吧，得搞定我的朋友。谢谢。谢谢。非常感谢。我会把这带上的。好吧，我懂了。你不知道那是辣妹组合的歌词。好吧，想象一下这有多痛苦。
Well, imagine what I thought, because I didn't know it was a lyric. I just thought he was just saying that stupid crazy sentence. No. Like, what? I was trying to connect it. Did you just call the Spice Girls
好吧，想象一下我是怎么想的，因为我不知道那是歌词。我以为他只是在说那句愚蠢疯狂的话。不对。像什么？我当时在试图把它们联系起来。你刚刚说辣妹组合……
stupid and crazy for the lyrics? Oh, well, not a lyric. If it was just as good by sentence for a podcast interview, and this is where I log off. What about when James Cameron, when James Cameron won the Academy Award for Best Director of Titanic, I had not seen the movie, but when he walks
因为歌词而愚蠢疯狂？哦，好吧，不是歌词。如果只是播客采访里的一句普通的话，这就是我退出的时候。詹姆斯·卡梅隆呢，当詹姆斯·卡梅隆凭《泰坦尼克号》赢得奥斯卡最佳导演奖时，我还没看过这部电影，但当他走……
up on stage, he says, I'm king of the world. Did you say you've never seen Titanic? At the time I had not seen it when I saw him go up on stage and say I'm king of the world. I got, oh, no, what did he just say? I've never seen it at all. Yeah. Oh my God. Because he got a lot of homework to do. Jason's Listening to want to be by this by his girls. Will you're watching Titanic and Sean just get get Ricky, you know, fix your cat. Thank you. Thank you. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Good night. Sean, you were right. Great. She didn't wash. It was sick. So nice. For a sick sick is a dog. This is worth. You know, when we do these late night records,
上台时，他说，我是世界之王。你是说你从来没看过《泰坦尼克号》？当时我确实没看过，当我看到他走上台说我是世界之王时，我心里想，哦，不，他刚才说什么？我压根没看过。对。哦，天哪。因为他有很多功课要做。杰森在听辣妹组合的《Wannabe》。威尔你在看《泰坦尼克号》，而肖恩只是，去修理一下你的猫吧。谢谢。谢谢。再见。再见。再见。再见。晚安。肖恩，你是对的。太棒了。她没洗。真有病。太好了。病得像只狗。这太值得了。你知道，当我们做这些深夜录音时，
it's, it's, you know, the, the, the stakes are high that it, that it, that it'd be a good guest. And you know, by the way, for the record, it was a 4 p.m. record. So when you say late night, for most people, they'll have a different. Okay. But the other thing is I will say this and this is a compliment to you, JB, not even a fucking, I'm not there's no punchline. She has a great work ethic, like a lot of people I know who started young in, who were young in as actors, direct whatever. She has that same thing and you have that same thing, which is she sick. But I, in all the years years I've done stuff with you.
这，这，你知道，赌注很高，希望它，它，它能成为一个好嘉宾。而且你知道，为了记录在案，这是一个下午4点录制的节目。所以当你说是深夜时，对大多数人来说，会有不同的看法。好吧。但另一件事是，我要这么说，这是对你的赞美，JB，甚至不是开玩笑，我不是，没有笑话梗。她有很棒的职业道德，就像我认识的许多很早就开始、很年轻就进入演艺圈的人一样，无论导演是谁。她有那种特质，你也有那种特质，那就是她生病了。但是，在我多年来和你一起做节目的日子里，
I've never known you to call in sick. Not fucking once. Yeah. Oh, there was plenty of times when I'd clear my day when it was three, three a.m. and I was still having fun. Oh, yeah, back. Sorry, except for when you blew your cool out when we were doing that fight scene on the rest of the government.
我从来不知道你请过病假。他妈的一次都没有。对。哦，有很多次我会把日程空出来，当时是凌晨三点，我还在玩得很开心。哦，对，以前。抱歉，除了你在我们拍那个政府餐厅打斗戏时情绪失控的那次。
You thought too hard. You broke my colon. I know that's true. But but anyway, she does have that great thing. She's always just a god. She's so good. You always when you start listening off the stuff that she does and they're also different. You're like,
你打得太猛了。你把我的结肠打破了。我知道那是真的。但是，不管怎样，她确实有那种绝佳的特质。她总是那么棒，简直是个神。她太棒了。每当你开始数她做过的事情，而且它们又是如此不同，你会觉得，
yeah, Mr. one actor is never sucked. Yeah, that's that's something. She's in that category. She's in that never sucked. It's I I was a John Good in that category. She's in that never sucked. It's I I was a John Goodman number one. He's the first guy I was thinking of when I think never as never sucked and she's in that category. There are a few people who fall into that category and she's one of them. Yeah, she's incredible. I didn't get to ask her about I want to talk more about La La Land about how it's got ready. Well,
对，这位演员从没演砸过。对，那是相当了不起。她属于那一类。她属于从没演砸过那一类。我是说，约翰·古德曼是头号人物。当我想到从没演砸过的人时，他是我第一个想到的，而她也属于那一类。很少有人能归入这一类，而她是其中之一。对，她太不可思议了。我还没来得及问她关于……我想多聊聊《爱乐之城》它是怎么准备的。好吧，
next time next time next time. Honestly, nobody better. Here comes who's got it. Yeah, well, I love Birdman too, you know. Oh, you know what I also like to see by by birdie. I couldn't even do it. I couldn't even, I'm Chris, you're gonna do that.
下次，下次，下次。老实说，没有人比她更好。谁来了，谁就搞定。对，我也很喜欢《鸟人》，你知道的。哦，你知道我还喜欢看什么，就是《小飞侠》（Bye Bye Birdie）。我甚至做不到。我甚至都不能，克里斯，你要这么做，
You're fired. Oh, by by birdie. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, That's good. I'll do. Bye, everybody. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness. Smartness.
你被解雇了。哦，《小飞侠》。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。这很好。我走了。再见，各位。Smartness。Smartness。Smartness。Smartness。Smartness。Smartness。
Smartness is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umbjurf. Smart loss. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Hi, it's me, the Grand Poova of Bahambad, the OG Green Grump, the Grinch. From Wondery! Tis the Grinch Holiday Talk Show is a pathetic attempt by the people of Ruvil to use my situation as a teachable moment. So, join me, the Grinch, along with Cindy Luhu.
Smartness由Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Umbjurf 100%有机纯手工制作。Smart loss。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或Wondry App上的Wondry Plus提前收听并免除广告。嗨，是我，巴汉巴德的大酋长，绿色老脾气，格林奇。来自Wondry！《格林奇假日脱口秀》是胡维尔镇人民试图利用我的处境作为一个有教育意义的时刻的可怜尝试。所以，加入我，格林奇，还有辛迪·露·胡。
Hello, everyone. And of course, my dog Max. Every week for this complete waste of time. Listen, as I launch a campaign against Christmas cheer, grilling celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire. Now try to get my heart to grow a few sizes, but it's not gonna work, honey. Your family will love the show!
大家好。当然，还有我的狗麦克斯。每周收听这个彻底浪费时间的节目。听我发起一场反对圣诞节欢乐的运动，把名人嘉宾烤得像明火上的栗子一样。现在试着让我的心脏长几码，但这是没用的，亲爱的。你的家人一定会喜欢这个节目的！
As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondery app, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show early and add free right now by joining Wondery Plus. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如你所知，我对小孩子可是出了名的好。在Wondry App或你获取播客的任何地方关注《格林奇假日脱口秀》。通过加入Wondry Plus，你可以立即提前且无广告地收听《格林奇假日脱口秀》。you 这个节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。